like service by your cable or satellite
provider
and now we're live with author and
publisher Steve Forbes the
editor-in-chief of Forbes magazine has
run twice for president and has authored
several books the most recent reviving
America for the next three hours it's
your opportunity to speak to mr. Forbes
steve forbes are the issues you talk
about and write about are they being
discussed you think in this election up
actually not the way they should be in
many ways this is the most content free
campaign we've had in decades
take the republican side most of the
candidates had nice position papers but
how many of them actually led with
issues the way i did with the flat tax
whatever you think of donald trump he at
least led with a diagnosis of a
prescription and even though i didn't
agree with a lot of it he put it out
there and what is amazing his sixteen
opponents didn't realize what he was
showing them if you lead with an issue
lead like you have conviction you can
get people's attention it's amazing and
that's why sometimes i shouldn't say
this especially on the air i fantasize
that maybe get joe stalin back for five
minutes and shoot all the political
consultants because they really don't
understand how you get a message across
in a way that the American people can
grasp and say yes this is the way we
should go well you've been talking about
the flat tax for a long time in fact
your second book was flat tax revolution
your most recent book is reviving
America
part of the subtitle is replacing the
tax code what exactly is a flat tax how
would it work what I would do is take
the current code get rid of it entirely
it's beyond redemption a couple of years
ago the head of the House Ways and Means
Committee the tax writing committee in
Congress before he retired put together
after several years of real effort a
bill to try to rationalize the current
code the bill came in at 997 pages which
tells you all you need to know so junk
the thing you used to say bury the tax
code but the EPA may not allow it since
it's so toxic but your take the throw
away the code put in a single rate we
recommend in the book 17% generous
exemptions for adults and for children
so nobody gets a tax increase in this
thing so for example a family of four
your first fifty two thousand eight
hundred dollars of salary is free from
federal income tax
no tax in your savings no death taxes
I've always believed you should be
allowed to leave the world unmolested by
the IRS do the same thing on the
corporate side not the rates down to 17
percent have immediate expensing of
capital expenditures so save on the
personal side above that 52,000 you only
pay 17 cents on the dollar you could
literally do your tax return on a single
sheet of paper or a few keystrokes on a
computer and by the way 40 countries
jurisdictions around the world I say
jurisdictions because places like Hong
Kong they're not a country but they are
self administrating have variations of
the flat tax so this is not the
laboratory theory this works in the real
world and how has it worked for those
other countries it's worked very well
almost all of them have kept the thing
and what it does is not only does it
create more growth because you can spend
your time working on the thing doing
real things instead of coping with the
tax code but also it's much easier to
administer and collect so the tax
evasion becomes that much more difficult
one of the complaints that we currently
have about our system is that not
everybody pays taxes do you believe that
everybody should pay taxes well I take a
little difference with some of my
colleagues on that one everyone who
works pays taxes you pay taxes on Social
Security and Medicare the so called FICA
taxes the government pretends that's not
a tax but a contribution for your future
retirement for pensions of health care
but in the real world it's a tax so and
it's from your first dollar of income so
you take a typical American if he or she
is working yes they're paying income
taxes to the feds one way or the other
and on the state level most states have
state income tax with very low levels of
thresholds so they're paying on that
level as well so no one's getting away
with the not paying taxes unless you're
just not part of the economy are you a
one-percenter I'm a one-percenter but
what the amazing thing is in terms and
this is one of the things we get to in
the book which we can discuss later Zhan
the whole subject of money is when you
have an unstable currency you do get
more sharper social divisions because
the economic stagnate
the 1% versus the 99 young versus old
public sector versus private sector the
47% versus the other 53% all of these
divisions people start to turn on each
other they don't know why the economy's
not moving so yes but in America at
least until recently before we had this
stagnation
is what was remarkable is how fluid our
situations were an economic life
you see our 400 richest list you're on
it one year you're off of it the next my
father liked to say in this economy do
you think you've arrived you're ready to
be shown the door nothing stays the same
the full subtitle of reviving America is
how repealing Obamacare replacing the
tax code and reforming the Fed will
restore hope and prosperity in it you
write that our health care system is
like a patient who has been misdiagnosed
and treated time and again with the
wrong medicine
he just keeps getting sicker six decades
of growing government involvement has
grossly distorted the health care system
it has indeed we point out in the book
nobody designed the system we have today
and by the way I don't care what
political persuasion you are no one is
happy with the system we have today
already now medical costs are starting
to really go up again and you go to a
hospital most people you know it's bad
enough traumatic enough to have to go to
the hospital but the experience leaves
them really shaken you wonder did the
specialists talk to each other to the
so-called hospitalists talk to each
other you say aunt tilly can't have a
certain medication and yet somehow is
she she ends up being administered the
medication
it's an unnerving experience and so the
system grew out of World War two they'd
wage and price controls with the
millions of people gone in the Armed
Services you had labor shortages here at
home you weren't allowed to pay people
more cash so companies started to pay
in-kind benefits big one health care
benefits in the government during the
war allowed it then after the war in the
1950s the IRS ruled that this could be
legitimately tax deduction for
businesses and not count as income to
employees so nobody designed the system
it grew Higley pigley but this gets to
the core of the problem
with healthcare is the lack of real free
markets the real customers are health
insurance companies government and
employers it's not the patient and
hospitals know for example they get
their revenue by how well they negotiate
with insurance companies and with the
government not how they satisfy patients
and we cite in the book it sounds a
little frivolous but I think it's very
telling where the patient really have
lies in this food chain is that the
crummiest motel in the world wouldn't
dare put you in a room with another
guest with a curtain in between a sick
guest no one does that get this routine
in hospitals crummy motel wouldn't there
give you a rope that looked like it came
out of the Salvation Army dumpster you
know these things are put on can't item
right so the patients is that patients
not really in control in the reforms we
propose in the book is to start to get
where the patient is really in control
and turn what looks like a hopeless
liability in terms of financial
liability cost keeping going up and up
into the most dynamic growth industry
ever does the Forbes company offer
health insurance to its employees oh
absolutely and that a good system where
the employer is offering the health
insurer no and but it grew as I say
nobody designed this thing and one of
the things we have the pioneered on long
before government sanction then was the
equivalent of health savings accounts we
give our people Forbes media $2,500 cash
during the course of the year you are in
charge of it if you don't if you're
blessed with good health you choose not
to spend the money you get to keep it if
you find a generic drug is better than a
regular prescription that savings is
yours not mine not the insurance company
not the government so we try to get
people to become conscious of costs
because it's in their benefit to do so
best interest to do so and so our costs
over time when you compare apples to
apples oranges oranges age groups and
all that sort of thing we haven't had
quite the problems that other company
set but we're a small outfit compared
obviously the rest of the economy but
that's what the kind of thing you need
more and more patients aren't
control of the resources so if you move
to another company that policy should go
with you what they call portability so
you're not chained to a company oh I
want to leave but I can't because I'm
going to lose these benefits and you
know what do I do
so we want to have liberation and again
patient control free markets when
allowed to work always turn scarcity
into abundance that will do so on
healthcare and get more effective safety
nets in the crazy system we have today
and we we do it in food yeah government
doesn't run out your cultures sooo
involved in agriculture pillaging run
out your culture did we'd have no more
obesity because we'd all be starving
they tried in Russian China didn't work
very so agriculture grows the food
companies process the food truckers
living foods sell food everywhere
supermarkets grocery stores hotels or
whatever and you've got problems you
have everything from food banks to food
stamp from food banks and the food
stamps to deal with it why can't we do
the same thing in health care have real
free enterprise real of productivity
real patient control and more effective
safety nets whether it's a high-risk
pools of alike where you will be covered
if a catastrophe hits you Steve Forbes
back to reviving America and taxes the
last thing we need is another half-baked
band-aid solution it's not enough to
simply cut tax rates and reduce the
number of tax brackets think of what
happened in 1986 after the code was
somewhat simplified numerous tax
shelters were eliminated and the number
of brackets was reduced to to 28 percent
and 15 percent but no sooner was the ink
dry on that legislation than Washington
politicians picked up their old habits
there have been more than 15,000 changes
to the code as Congress at the behest of
a swarm of locusts like lobbyists snuck
in clauses and amendments to favor
particular individuals companies
industries nonprofits and causes yes and
that gets to why hopefully next year
we'll get some serious tax reform but
that's why you have to have a single
rate in 86 we had two rates as we point
out in the book putting two tax rates
together
is like putting two rabbits together
they breed they multiply when you have a
single rate you want to change it
everyone sees it everyone knows they're
going to be affected by it so it's a
real insurance against what happened 30
years ago last tried to simplify the
code by the way this also shows trying
to deal reform with the code as we have
it today impossible that 86 act
simplification and it came to 800 pages
of something so again just roll the
thing out start all over and by the way
those who worry about am I going to lose
my charity deduction or mortgage and all
that sort of thing do a variation where
Hong Kong does give people a choice you
can go with the new system or if you
lack self-esteem you want to punish
yourself each year and stay with the old
go ahead you know but this way you lower
the temperature you say to people don't
trust me see for yourself which one is
better
I think 99 percent by the way we want to
when we talk about taxes we get all hung
up on you know GDP and revenues and
crossing lines and all that sort of
thing think of it as an opportunity cost
just go back 20 years the IRS estimates
we spend 6 billion hours a year filling
out tax forms experts estimate we spent
200 billion dollars plus complying with
this monstrosity just think over 20
years tens of billions of hours
trillions of dollars immense brainpower
some very bright people are involved in
this thing imagine if all those
resources have gone to new products new
services new medical devices new cures
for diseases how much better off we'd be
what economists call the opportunity
cost that is the real more immoral
Travis travesty immorality in the
current code it's what it's taking away
from us not just in the imbecility of it
the corruption of it but what we've lost
because we spent our resources on
something totally unnecessary my guess
is your taxes are more complicated than
most people's have you ever estimated or
figured out how much time money has been
spent doing your taxes yeah it's
terrific
forty years ago I could actually do my
return back in the 1970s I always have
an account
look over it couldn't trust myself but I
could understand me understand the thing
earlier became impossible in the
equations and the things you have to do
you know one eighth of this one third of
that and then to line subtract line 7a
and if it's more than 7b you got to go
to HC I mean and by the way one things
we point out in the book is oh whoa I
have good software to help me do it
well we point out depending on your
circumstances different software
packages will give you different
estimates of what your tax liability is
even they the gods we worship are the
software must have it aren't getting it
right
nobody can in 1999 in your first book a
new birth of freedom the dirty little
secret in Washington what the
politicians really fear from tax relief
and Tax Simplification is not a loss of
revenue but they really fear is a loss
of power complexity is power and for
example here in Washington we are today
if you remember the House Ways and Means
Committee which is the tax writing
committee in Congress
you remember that committee your set for
political life you say I think I'll have
a reception tonight every lobbyist comes
along with a check yes I need access
I'll contribute to your campaign or PAC
or whatever it is you want and this way
they have power you have to go to them
either to protect yourself or try to
shaft an opponent or something with the
code is being driven away there's hurt
and hurting your industry of business so
you always have to come to them
absolutely like you always have to come
to them which means checks people on
about it from reviving America our
nation seems mired in a malaise that
evokes comparisons with the 1970s is
this uncertain polarized and
economically stagnant America the new
normal no some people like Larry Summers
former Secretary of the Treasury
talks about this this new era as if it's
a from aliens from space and something
the new forces of history it's
absolutely not
since me what we've gone through today
is a result of policy errors the nice
thing about errors is they can be
corrected that's why we did the book
obviously a lot of things that have to
be done but we focused on big three
reforms get those right and by golly
this economy will come roaring back
we've been through these periods before
we had a terrible decade in the 30s
after the war we put in reforms we came
roaring back same thing in the 70s
malaise decade came roaring back in the
80s and 90s we were we can do it again
the third part of your subtitle is
reforming the Fed now your friend Ron
Paul has written in the Fed but you're
at reforming the Fed and here's what you
write we may be in awe of the feds high
priests that they can no more guess the
need for money than the central planners
could run an economy in the days of the
Soviet Union absolutely this idea that a
handful of people that the Fed can
determine what interest rates are how
banks should be run what the money
supply should be is preposterous the
Soviet Union fell and we point out in
the book what the Fed has done since the
first ball weakening the dollar which
started under a Republican
administration this is bipartisan
nonsense here there in the early part of
the last decade started weakening a
dollar
that's why commodity prices went up
that's why housing prices went up and
led to the disaster of 2008 since 2008
the Fed is still misbehaved take for
example this whole thing on zero
interest rates should they raise
interest rates controlling interest
rates as like price controls they're
deforming the market the Fed should be
out of it they can set the rate they'll
lend money to bank that so-called
discount windows they've always done
that's legitimate but in terms of trying
to set the price of borrowing and
lending for the rest of the economy it's
like the Soviet Union it is distorted
the market for example bonds they've
they don't know when they know they did
this they created a credit market today
where the favoritism goes to bonds
corporate bonds government bonds and who
can issue bonds usually big companies
and obviously governments what has
happened if you look at the credit where
credit is gone since 2008 since the Fed
started this nonsense to small
businesses new businesses households
tiny killing the creation of new
businesses killing the expansion of
small businesses which is a key reason
why in addition to over-regulation why
for the first time in memory of small
businesses aren't being created in the
numbers we've traditionally had since
2009 a number of creation of small
businesses a fraction of what they were
after previous recessions and we know
small businesses new businesses or where
the innovation comes from and where job
creation comes from not from the biggies
but from the new ones that hopefully
tomorrow is biggies it's not happening
we have periods where businesses are
going companies are going out of
business at a faster rate than new
companies are being created that is
brand new goes against what one of the
great strengths of this country the
ability to always come up with new and
greater companies back in the 70s who
ever heard of Microsoft who ever heard
of FedEx whoever heard of Apple and
other companies am gen they all started
as little companies in the 70s became
the biggies of the 90s and today we're
not getting that kind of creation and
that's the slow kind of rot that any
people sense but can't put their fingers
on but aren't low interest rates
politically popular well as homeowners
yeah we like well it's like the old
Soviet Union where they said the
healthcare is free but you can't get any
in the low rates today yes they favor
that but how much real home building has
been done again oh they say was better
than 2009 I would hope so but in terms
of the needs of this economy still not
where it should be you try to one of the
reasons you don't have mobility the way
used to you you you want to move from
here to Texas or Oregon or wherever can
I get a mortgage there can the person
who wants to buy my house here get a
mortgage very very uncertain so the
rates are low but they've deformed the
marks like having a rent controlled
apartment great if you don't mind the
lack of
upkeep because landlord won't give you
much upkeep but in terms of creating new
apartments new housing new new
businesses doesn't work so the feds have
deformed the mark just give one
statistic I always hate to do this
because it drives people away but in the
last five years credit the government
has grown 37% credit to corporations 32%
credit the small businesses and
households only 6% devastating figures
specially compared to the past that's
one reason why we are labor market is so
bad I mean they even putting aside how
many people dropped out people are not
getting the jobs they should a lot of
part-time jobs people don't want any
sort of a lousy job report last month
which was bad enough and what they call
the establishment survey where they go
to existing companies but then they have
called the household survey which is
better to overtime at picking out new
businesses that are rising up that
haven't come on the government's radar
yet pump job creation there so across
the board we're still stuck in second
gear like a baseball player
yeah maybe we've raised our average from
180 to 220 but ain't going to win us the
World Series Steve Forbes I think I saw
a stat that 90 million people are not in
the u.s. job market are on this yes that
came out with that the labor market
report you see it in what they call the
labor force participation rate Louis has
been since the 1970s remembers the 70s
studied see a real surge of women coming
into the workforce really really ramped
up so well we're going back to the
dinosaur age and not because people have
suddenly dropped out because well I
don't really want to work anymore
because they don't have the opportunity
from your book how capitalism will save
us Alan Greenspan's policies undermined
free markets Iran wouldn't not have
succumb to the temptation to believe
that a government agency like the Fed
could fine-tune the American and global
economies this guess again gets the
conceit that a handful of people in
Washington or in the European Central
Bank
the Bank of Japan the Bank of England
can determined what the price of money
should be how the economy should grow
they treat the economy as if it were a
machine the economy is in this country
320 million individuals and it's adding
up what all 300 million of us do we're
not a machine and when when the Fed does
something it effects economy in
different ways and so we've seen central
plan did not work the Soviet Union the
Chinese are still grappling with trying
to be with the old and with the new get
their economy modernized and yet the Fed
thinks that it can guide the economy
that by manipulating interest rates they
can determine what the right price is
and what the economy should do and it is
just as scandalous just one little thing
Janet Yellen who heads the Fed today
says and so do our colleagues we need 2%
inflation that's a way of saying price
should go up two percent a year and a
family making $50,000 a year how in the
world is raising the cost of living for
a family a thousand dollars a year
stimulate the economy I haven't figured
out I don't think they have manifestly
they haven't or else we'd have a more
vibrant economy today was is some of our
monetary policy today a result of the
high inflation of the 70s
we're fearful of that well what the 70s
should have taught us is when you don't
have a sound currency when you don't
have a currency that is a stable value
you're going to be it's like a watch
that can't tell time with a dollars weak
or strong it's like a watch that's too
slow or too fast neither one's going to
help you very much and so what we should
have learned from the 70s is stability
is better than instability a watch that
can tell time is better than one that
can't but that lesson is just lost on
these people are you a deficit hawk up
you have to be very careful of that
because
some who say we don't like deficits they
love spending which means they want to
raise taxes so Milton Friedman years ago
famously said he would rather have a
government that shows how out-of-date
this is but he said he'd rather have a
government with a budget of 1 trillion
that was in serious deficit and a
government that spent 2 trillion with
the budget balanced whether you borrow
the money or whether you tax the money
will you try to print the money one way
or the other you're taking real resource
this is one of the myths that government
somehow creates resources
it doesn't one of the points we make in
this book is money is not wealth it's a
claim you know you go to a restaurant
you check your coat you get a piece of
plastic or a piece of paper worthless in
and of itself puts a claim on the coat
money is a claim on products and
services has no intrinsic value it's
based on trust and so when you start
mucking around with the with the the
ability of what that piece of paper can
buy again take take our clock imagine
the Fed floated the clock 60 minutes an
hour one day 40 minutes the next 80
minutes the day after we know life would
be chaotic right let's say you you bake
in a cases bake the batter 30 minutes is
that nominal minutes inflation-adjusted
minutes is it a Washington minute a
Mexican minute a New York minute be
chaotic but that's what they do with the
money money is a claim and so when you
start to muck around with it get
problems so the gold standard up there's
so many myths and we deal with them in
the book reviving America and the money
book up about the gold standard the gold
standard is not using gold coins that
would be highly inefficient go buy a
pair of socks at Walmart the twelve
hundred dollar gold coin no not not very
efficient think of gold as a ruler gold
keeps its intrinsic value better than
anything else when you see the price
dollar price fluctuate each day that's
the value of the dollar fluctuating
people's perceptions now and in the
future
gold for 4,000 years for a variety of
reasons keeps its intrinsic guy not
perfectly but better than anything else
had a gold standard 480 years in this
country in the 1792 1970s we went
through a depression Civil War two world
wars countless crises in between and yet
we achieved the highest economic growth
rates in the history of the world if we
had maintained the same growth rates
that we did for that hundred eighty
years in the last 40 years our economy
today would be eight trillion dollars
bigger because the way you get an
economy way would get a higher standard
of living is by investing doing new
things expanding businesses starting new
businesses new products new services
that takes investment that's risky
enough most investments don't work out
but if you don't know whether you're
going to get back a hundred cent dollar
an 80 cent dollar 10 cent dollar we get
less investment so it's no surprise
since we started to muck around
seriously muck around 80s and 90s got
about a C on monetary policy after the
disaster of the 70s then we went back to
of mucking around again and look at
business investment stagnant when anyone
asked me should i buy invest in gold I
know we have a problem buying metal
buying an object great piece of art but
that's not an investment then I know we
have a problem
you should be investing in the things
that are today unseen new businesses new
factories bigger inventory when you do
things like that already exists means
people are without them realizing of
protecting what they have and also you
go to commodities oil oil is one of the
oldest commodities around 150 years when
in the 70s when we devalue the dollar
constantly went from 3 to 40 dollars a
barrel everyone thought oh he must be
running out of this stuff then when we
conquered the terrible inflation the 80s
only went down to ten ten dollars a
barrel crashed stabilized to 20 to 25
then in the early part of the last
decade went back at it suddenly went up
to 100 oh we must be running out of the
stuff well I have alternative long
yellow and we went back on it
and so well when when things that are
already around like gold like copper
like land unless it's in a hot area when
oil oil and those things go up housing
prices go up sharply house that was
worth a hundred thousand yesterdays or
120 thousand tomorrow same house no
improvements you got a problem steve
forbes do you believe that we're living
in a bifurcated economy in the sense
that we have the haves and the have-nots
in the middle classes is shrinking what
what we have we have a stagnant economy
is what we've had for a decade tens of
millions of people and over half the
population their real incomes haven't
gone up that's a historical in america
that's not the new normal that's a new
abnormal and again when those things
happen people can't grasp why why is it
that you know prices seem to go up a
little bit
health care goes up college goes up and
my income is not really going up i just
can't seem to get out of this thing like
those nightmares we're you know and
Quagmire and just can't get out of the
thing you get the real dissatisfaction
don't you see it in this country see it
around the world people don't understand
why are we in this rut why aren't things
better why the people in authority can't
create an environment where we can get
this train back on the track again from
your book how capitalism will save us
this is Warren Buffett if you are in the
luckiest 1% of humanity you owe it to
the rest of humanity to think about the
other 99% and that's been the tradition
in this country going back from the
beginning we tend to think that America
is the most philanthropic nation in the
world and people wonder why are we the
most commercial nation and the most
philanthropic Commerce is about meaning
you succeed in true free markets by
meeting the needs and wants of other
people even if you lust for money you
don't get it unless the government's
behind you unless you provide something
that somebody else wants I think with
Steve Jobs when
asked you do marketing surveys he said
then no because people don't know what
they want until I show them putting
putting something out there and and so
free markets will turn scarcity into
abundance free markets do work if you
allow them but when you put in huge
regulations and just the one one example
the federal criminal code they can't
count the number of crimes that are in
that code now last system was five
thousand he put in the regulations
three hundred thousand it was a
professor he writes for us and the
famous defense attorney Harvey
silverglade estimated he wrote a book
called three felonies a day he said any
professional without that person knowing
it commits several felonies a day
innocently because they have no idea
these complex vaguely written rules and
laws that emanate from here you see it
on the state level as well that is not
right and again that contributes to the
frustration so you have all these regs
and there was an estimate of several
years ago that a company with 19 or
fewer employees complying with
regulations costs almost eleven thousand
dollars per employee for companies with
five hundred through over seven thousand
so this is why the big companies are
doing very nicely most them small and
medium-sized companies are struggling
again killed by the tax code killed by
this growth of regulation killed by the
unstable dollar in these on certain
credit markets from your book freedom
manifesto for twenty years
Microsoft paid no attention to
Washington the result a mammoth
antitrust action that dragged on for
years costing the company billions of
dollars in fines and legal fees today
the company has a major presence in
Washington DC and employs numerous
powerful lobbying firms and individual
lobbyists to protect its interests
Facebook which became a multi-billion
dollar giant in the few years since it
was founded know for was not about to
make the same mistake in 2011 the
company
concerned by potential government
privacy restrictions opened up a
spanking new 8,000 square foot office in
Washington with a staff that includes a
former Privacy expert from the ACLU
Google another startup turned giant is
spending each year many millions of
dollars on lobbing yes and this tells
you something about the scope of
government today if you reach a certain
size you have to pay tribute to the
powers that be or they'll come and get
you and then it turns from protection
that's a protection racket from
protection to cronyism which is one of
the things that people are really upset
about today late a recent example of it
of agency buried inside the Federal
Reserve came out with which is that
agency is unconstitutional but I think
eventually be thrown out they came out
with rules over over 1000 doing pages
rules that are going to put the
so-called payday lenders out of business
one of the advocacies of that was Google
which said few weeks ago wasn't going to
allow payday lenders to advertise guess
who has an investment in a company
that's going to Camus Vinh to that
market as these people are put out of
business
Google cronyism does Forbes have a
lobbyist here in Washington DC no but
we're members and work with magazine
publishers Association and the like but
since we're now more internet online
postal rates don't quite have the same
impact they did in days past but but
again when they talk about out of how do
we occur ball this lobbying in
Washington you can put all the
restrictions that you know you have to
be out of Congress for 500 years before
you can join a lobbying firm all these
things things they put in you can't have
lunches and things like that if you have
a problem with mosquitoes you've got to
get the bad water got a drain the fetid
swamp you've got to reduce the scope of
government and otherwise guarantee one
way or the other people find ways to
petition
government especially when that holds
life-and-death decision over their own
existence human nature steve forbes
we've been talking about this for 250
years in this country you've been
talking about this for your entire
career
why hasn't it changed part of all that
we in capitals and will save us we
quickly hit this was a very until the
Great Depression we as we do today we
had the largest economy in the world the
most sophisticated economy nor the most
complex country in the world and we had
also the smallest central government in
the world state governments are three
times the size of the federal government
then came the Great Depression and one
of the things that came out of World War
one when they temporarily nationalized
industries massive controls was AHA that
worked during the war why can't we do it
in peacetime bigger government presence
get rid of this wasteful competition and
let's science rain experts rain and the
glory will be here well clearly that has
not worked out very well but one of the
things and we hit that in freedom
manifesto is that it's not enough to say
free markets work government in many
areas does not work very well
Veterans Administration and the like
it's not I'm not to say that because
government always says well we may mess
up we may screw up we may hurt the
people that we are supposed to help but
our hearts in the right places we occupy
the high moral ground business grubby
you know they you can't trust them true
the matter is explained again the
morality of free markets is Kru free
markets not cronyism is meeting the
needs and wants of other people it has
people where they even know it
trying to figure out how to make you
happy by what you're offering it reduces
barriers between people contrary to myth
may not love your neighbor but you sure
want to sell to your neighbor and so
that's why we have this complex global
supply chain people all working making
products you take a typical product
today involves
thousands of people parts made the
pieces of it all around the world you
take the iPhone the iPad 10 purse $10 of
those parts are made here the rest are
all from around the world but it gives
us so it it's not just they deliver the
goods it has a moral basis meeting the
needs and wants of other people allowing
creativity look at these entrepreneurs
who rise out from the most strangest
backgrounds and they learn in free
markets take Steve Jobs if you took that
personality and presented it to a Human
Resources person today about the name on
it say that's not the person we'd want
here he was all in his younger days he
was a grand Iser taking other people's
ideas not giving people credit putting
people down that's why he's fired from
his own company before the age of 30 but
the amazing story about him is he
learned become an effective leader how
to bring others together to get
something done it was painful he had a
lot of setbacks but he learned in a free
market many people are not born beaters
they learn from experience and he's a
prime example of it so that's what free
markets are about always turning
scarcity into abundance you know that
first cell phone we had 30 years ago
from Motorola big as a shoebox waiting
like a brick 40 minute battery life
$3,995 today they give them away you can
get a good smartphone even run out of
plan from a Verizon or anybody else for
a hundred bucks
zoom down to 50 bucks we now become so
spoiled I grew up with the thing called
card catalogs remember those in
libraries are now you have it instantly
in front of you we're so spoiled now
that if we place a call to a shepherd in
outer mongolia and it takes longer than
10 seconds we say boy there's a piece of
crap why why isn't working faster and
that that's what free markets does
always turn scarcity into abundance if
you let them are you a technology user
yes and the nice thing is since I'm a
klutz of technology that's what I loved
about the the iPad you touch it and
something happens and
that's the thing you don't have to be an
engineer to drive an automobile you
don't have to be technologist to be able
to use this stuff and oftentimes the
people who do best are not the ones who
invented are the ones who learn how to
use the invention we take for example
the mainframe computer one of the big
things that came out of World War two
originally designed to make it easier to
calculate where artillery shells would
go very complicated mathematics computer
zombies can do that very quickly
obviously computers had many more
applications in artillery shell
trajectories but you know made the most
money from it wasn't the originator of a
Sperry
it was IBM's competitors all went by the
wayside IBM twenty-five years ago nearly
went bust
hill made the most money from the
mainframe Sam Walton 50 years ago small
northwestern Arkansas retailer at the
time Kmart 50 times the size of Walmart
but Walton realized he could use these
new machines develop special software to
manage his inventories better than
anyone else and then supply chains
better than anyone else that was this
secret sauce he used an invention better
than anyone else well I think it's in
reviving America that you and your
co-author Elizabeth Ames talk about how
Google buys smaller computers millions
of them yes and if they you know to do
what they do and then they throw one
away if it needs to be thrown away yes
like I like a pen disposable and at the
time again we think Google's is big
giant today but in the 90s it was
nothing two young kids going against
Microsoft Yahoo is a big deal at the
time
mammoth company how are you going to go
against these giants and search engines
well these two guys Bren and Paige
recognized that search engines should be
like the brain one cell not very
impressive put them together it is
impressive so they strapped these
devices together you say one doesn't
work don't bother to fix it not worth it
just put another winning that's why one
of the things they don't like you to
know is their mammoth uses of
electricity
that's why they go where hydropower is
another access to a lot of cheap
electricity mammoth user electricity but
they it worked
they beat the big guys at their own game
good afternoon and welcome to book TV on
c-span - this is our monthly in-depth
program where we invite one author on to
talk about his or her body of work this
month its author publisher presidential
candidate Steve Forbes he is the author
of several books beginning in 1999 his
first book a new birth of freedom vision
for America flat-tax revolution using a
postcard to abolish the IRS came out in
2005 power ambition glory which we
haven't touched on yet but we will came
out in 2009 how capitalism will save us
why free people and free markets are the
best answer in today's economy also came
out in onine freedom manifesto why free
markets are moral and big government
isn't 2012 and in 2014 how the
destruction of the money is the name of
the book how the destruction of the
dollar threatens the global economy and
this past year reviving America how
repealing Obamacare replacing the tax
code and reforming the Fed will restore
hope and prosperity this is an
interactive program and we want to hear
from you and there are several ways for
you to participate in our program and
talk with mr. Forbes you can phone 2:02
is the area code for all of our numbers
7 for 8 8200 if you live in the East and
central time zones seven four eight
eight two zero one for those of you in
the mountain and Pacific time zones you
can also send an email to book TV at
c-span 0rg you can make a Twitter
comment at book TVs our Twitter handle
and you could make a comment on Facebook
as well facebook.com slash book TV now
we have one other way for you to contact
Steve Forbes today and that's with a
text message using technology here is
the number this is only for text this is
not for phone calls if you want to send
a text from your phone five one zero
three four zero five five five
nine one more time the text message
number is five one zero three four zero
five five five nine and we'll begin
taking those calls and comments in just
a few minutes here on book TV Steve
Forbes Elizabeth Eames is a co-author on
a lot of your books who is she she's a
person involved in the public relations
and communications actually work with us
back in the 1990s and went out on her
own started her own firm called bold
communications and so we've done several
books together I also did one with John
previs a classicist you mentioned a
power ambition glory and it can help
when you get to people if they don't
kill each other by the end of the
process which is always a danger in
terms of interacting and getting
something more sharply home and perhaps
you trying to do it on your own so what
is your process with an Elizabeth Eames
or a John previs to write do you come up
with the idea do they approach you about
the idea on power ambition glory John
previs approached me and the idea he got
to know me I got to know him I did a
review of a book he did on Hannibal
crossing the Alps and he's about to come
out with a major biography of Hannibal
and he had the idea said you know I'm
doing a book on ancient leaders like
Alexander the Great
maybe you could work and bring in modern
business leaders last hundred years and
there are common leadership lessons and
one of the things that quickly became
apparent was that both times and
circumstances obviously changed between
the world we have today in the world of
2,500 2,000 years ago human nature does
not the attributes of effective
leadership don't change
that's what's so fascinating it's about
people whether the ancient world or the
current of the world we have today how
people respond how people respond to
crisis opportunities one things you
learn is effective leaders are always
innovators but you also learn you're
never master of the universe no matter
how smart you are no matter how
you are other forces come to play well
who was Hannibal and in your book power
ambition glory you compare Hannibal to
Google up because Hannibal was an
innovator his country Bank Carthage had
been beaten by the Romans in the first
what they call the First Punic War and
the Carthage wanted not only revenge but
realize that if they didn't knock out
Rome Rome was going to knock out them
one or the other was going to dominate
and so the Romans thought that if
Carthage which then had a great Navy if
a Carthage was going to go against Rome
it would take a southern route would
land in southern Italy men work their
way up to Rome and Hannibal came up with
the idea why not go and hit Rome from
the north where they would not expect it
go through Spain go up and Italy go
through the Alps with elephants they
were very good in a sort of like animal
tanks and hit them where they don't know
where they least expected he was an
innovator not only in terms of that kind
of strategy but in terms of battle
strategy and a traditional set battle
the Romans could never accept at the
very end Romans could never be
compatible and however why didn't he win
because again he didn't control his
universe Carthage politicians and
Carthage would not give him the
necessary resources to finish the job
and when at the end of filming Skippy Oh
both moon mr. Skippy africanus a very
interesting leader himself his father
and uncle had been killed fighting
Hannibal
instead of just raging he said the best
revenge is success
he studied Hamilton Hannibal studied his
tactics a strategy got to know Hannibal
probably better than Hannibal knew
himself and did a reverse Hannibal he
had to fight tooth and nail to convince
the Romans to allow him to do this the
army got him to do this but he took an
army and went and reversed what Hannibal
did he went into Spain and then he went
from Spain
mean into threatening North Africa where
Carthage was and when the Carthaginians
thought they might have to face a Roman
army they sent word to Hannibal and
Italy instead come home you must defend
us Hannibal said to Carthage he said you
can handle that he's not going to
overthrow you but he said if you call me
back I'll never get back to Italy again
and we've lost the war they still called
them back and they lost the war from
power and bishan glory in the ranks of
corporate leadership a crucial mistake
is attributing the success of a company
solely to the skills and charisma of one
individual it's heroic CEO yes and one
of theirs thankfully a whole body of new
literature coming out now especially
with big companies is that one person
can't do everything an effective leader
recognizes but he or she can do best and
is able to assemble teams to fill in
when you can't do it there may be a
particular job you could do better than
the person who is doing it but is that
the best use of your time one of the
challenges of Donald Trump's campaign is
he's running that almost by himself he
needs teams if he's going to be
effective in this general election
otherwise he they'll overwhelm them but
in terms of a company now they're
discovering more and more how do you
become innovative when you become large
you do it with small teams Jeff Bezos so
as an effective team he has the to pizza
rule when you put a team together eight
ten twelve people gets bigger than that
he said it takes more than two pizzas
when they work late at night the team's
not going to work
research shows eight ten twelve people
effective team leader you can get a real
job done and effectively and so how do
you get this done
one person preposterous just like trying
to run a country with central planners
not going to work
you've got to tap in to the brain power
and how you do that and we were
discovering hierarchy may not be the
best way to do it and how do you develop
these teams we see it in sports all the
time the military spec very good then
the platoon level developing teams to
get the particular jobs done and so an
effective leader will recognize you know
maybe he or she won't watch the parade
to the press and say I'm the genius but
in the heart of hearts they got to know
and this is what Steve Jobs learned you
have to have effective people who cannot
execute who can come of creative ideas
your task is to make judgments about
what works and doesn't work and what
brings companies down just by the way on
jobs one of the things that haunted him
was what happened to Sony after World
War two a new company dominated the
whole noodle electronic world and then
it faltered and part of the reason it
faltered was it became a series of
fiefdom of products of tasks Nunn talked
to the other and so he feared that he
did not want that to happen Apple so
when he designed their new building in
California Cupertino he even things like
where the restrooms were he made sure
they're located with people from
different departments different product
development teams would you know run
right into each other and when they do
hires for major jobs wouldn't just be
the department where this person might
work you'd have other various parts that
company become involved so you wouldn't
get this built-in fiefdom us-versus-them
and the lack of cooperation so in making
a large organization work a small one
yeah one person can do it but a large
one we better know how to have effective
teams you can guide them if you think
you can do it yourself tell me who that
person there's no short the stock Steve
Forbes is somebody whose name is
well-known and whose name is on the
company is it is it tempting is it
addicting is it intoxicating to to maybe
take credit up well the success is the
ultimate credit and and one of the one
of the challenges and this this is true
of anything would you see it in business
all the time is what happens when your
world is changed the rise of the web
destroyed everything I've learned my and
my family had learned and all of our
people had learned
you know the model from gone back the
1830s the riders of the steam press
destroyed in fact we had to start all
over easy to say extremely hard to do
which is why often it's outsiders who
make the big changes not the incumbents
because they're not weighed with
legacies one of the things that
executives always have to remind
themselves what Peter Drucker the late
great management guru once said he said
companies should always ask themselves
what is your purpose what is your
mission what is it you are trying to do
if you try to focus on what your
ultimate purpose is you don't get quite
as hung up if the means to achieve that
purpose are fundamentally change and we
and part of the you know we live in an
era where you can either they say you
can eat well or sleep well eat well part
I can do sleep well is quite another
matter because things are constantly
changing and there's no playbook
there's no turnaround book here's what
you do when your models been destroyed
you're inventing it as you go along so
you have to be prepared you will make
mistakes you are in unchartered waters
so it's great for the consumer they're
getting great new things great new
services but for those running it by
golly can have some very tense moments
how did you respond well thankfully we
recognized made good decision back 20
years ago when the web first came along
and publishers thought I Goti will take
the printed page put it on the screen
and we're an electronic publishing which
is sort of the equivalent when over 100
years ago 120 years ago movies were
invented some people thought that you
just film a stage play that would be a
feature film no two different mediums so
in the mid 90s we took our new website
we put it in a separate building
separate staff separate support system
why critical reason was if you put that
in with the same line of structure
Authority it will get crushed because it
will be bent not out of
the immediate needs are the print side
so he didn't want the baby to get
crushed in the crib so he added as a
separate entity
ten years later became time to unite
them and we had a horrific problem in
uniting two different cultures the
journalists on the website or the ocean
save journals from the print side
thought that the web writers were
peasants you know just turn out trash
you know common with and the web people
thought the print people were print
journalists were just the lazy snobs who
didn't do very much turned out an
article every two weeks and thought
they're doing something so trying to
mesh those together very difficult many
people couldn't make the transition
today it seems common knowledge you
master both but it was hard to do
content creation we still turn out
twelve thirteen hundred printed articles
a year or on the web now we do over one
hundred and twenty thousand submissions
we have over 1800 contracted
contributors very different model but
again serving the needs but very
different and now we're facing the
challenge I think we're doing it better
than most our people I'm not I
thankfully we have people with us and
know what they're doing but facing the
challenge of handhelds mobile devices
very difficult for advertising so it's
constant
my father said again you think you've
arrived you're ready to be shown the
door especially now in this fast-paced
world nothing stays the same
what is Forbes media today Forbes media
goes back in terms of getting to Drucker
Singh on purpose
there's our profound belief in
entrepreneurial capitalism the first
issue of the magazine my grandfather was
an immigrant to this country came with
8th grade education EC 4dc Forbes very
little money came from Scotland he said
the purpose of business is to produce
happiness not to pile up money and so
that's been our ethos since and so in
that sense one of our editors like to
say we're like a drama critic
we love it when the production is done
right hate it when they botch it and so
that's that that's what we that's a we
that's our that's our central purpose
giving people the analysis the tools to
be successful that's why we focus so
much on people it's not the big
impersonal forces all gets down to
people my grandfather like to say he
said you'll get to know the prospects of
a company better by focusing on the head
knock of the tree called CEOs and you
will up the balance sheet good leaders
good people and turn it down bad balance
sheet into the golden one and bad
leadership seen time and again can
destroy even the most seemingly
impregnable balance sheet what are some
of the publications today mr. Forbes
that your company puts out we the main
one is still what we call the mothership
Forbes magazine we have a number of
investment newsletters we have a Forbes
Asia Forbes Europe so we have various
publications but the key thing is now
more and more electronics we have over
36 licensed editions of Forbes around
the world local partner
we're not conceited enough to think we
know every market in the world
so they license it about normally it
varies depending on the arrangement not
half the content will come from us if
the content will be created for their
own local market so that print side is
doing well but we're doing more and more
on the electronic side more and more of
our traffic is coming from around the
world no surprise what is your role
today my role today is to help out on
the marketing side the promotion side a
lot of the day-to-day stuff is now done
by others but I still have a day job and
and I think given given what what's
amazing around the world is the power of
the Forbes brand and the reason there's
not size or anything like that I think
that entrepreneurs are
the world sense with us were on the same
page we understand your life decisions
understand what you're trying to do and
so we don't see you as miscreants we
don't see you as something that has to
be quashed or tolerated because you
deliver the goods we see them as a noble
pursuit now human nature being what it
is
any of them don't do noble things but I
think they sense what you might call the
entrepreneurial class people striving
starting with nothing to create
something they sense that we're on the
same page how would you think that your
leadership style is different from your
father's Malcolm Forbes well in terms of
some of the things he is famous for I
don't ride motorcycles
he was very flamboyant in that sense and
they said for decades I'm always too
young to ride a motorcycle I'd kill
myself in the balloons and he was very
very outgoing and but one of the things
he taught me and my siblings was he said
don't try to imitate others we can take
inspiration from others but if you try
to imitate do it because somebody else
did it he said you'll send yourself to
an early grave he said each of you will
develop your own way of doing things and
it will be constantly evolving he had
his own he changed from what he was in
his 30s and 40s to what he was in his
60s and that's a vestige up people who
are working and in a world that changes
you don't chuck everything aside try to
keep the core but you have to adapt to
changing circumstances of the leaders
that you profile in power ambition glory
Cirrus Xenophon Alexander the Great
Hannibal Julius Caesar and Augustus
where would you put yourself where would
you put your father my father would
probably be a combination of in terms of
knowing the importance of having that
brand image would be an Alexander Warren
Augustus who recognized how you appear
is critical in terms of what kind of
ability and power you have but I think
the one that impressed me the most was
Xenophon not not a household word today
but an extraordinary story he was an
Athenian Nerissa Kratt and as a lark
young man decided to go with a group of
Spartan mercenaries mostly Spartans
there's some other Greek States mixed in
but 10,000 mostly Spartans mercenaries
go fight in one of these succession wars
in Persia two sons two brothers were
joking with each other to succeed the
dead father and the Spartans were hired
by one of the brothers and so Xenophon
went along as sort of a lark and at the
time as you know in history the
Athenians and the Spartans hated each
other they're the two dominance they
they they they despise one another and
but they tolerated Xenophon because you
just gone along for the ride well they
backed the wrong horse so here they are
in the middle of Persia 10,000 the
opposing army of the brother who won
hundreds of thousands Spartans fought
well but they think they brother did not
they're working for so here they are
looked hopeless they sent a delegation
the Spartans did to negotiate with the
winning brother to try to buy passage
way out back to Greece we killed them
all and so the Spartans thought this is
the end that no lines of communication
in the middle of nowhere hostile
territory and so Xenophon spontaneously
didn't go to a military academy got up
and gave a rousing speech saying we can
find a way out of this stirred them and
they said okay in effect
lead the way and he was smart enough he
realized at the beginning he would not
must not take the lead others be the
front people because he was an athenian
and also and then in those days in terms
of the army you had to persuade
the soldiers gotta talk to them
assemblies we just couldn't say given
order say we're going to march here dad
to persuade them and if he didn't
persuade them or they decide to replace
you he didn't get a golden parachute
they stone you so this is high stakes
but only he became the effective leader
they got out their moments when it
looked like would be lost when you like
he might get stoned but what it
demonstrates a couple things one is
circumstances they come that you could
never anticipate and you have to rise to
it even if you feel you're not ready
have to just step in and say got to do
the best I can
rather and I've got to risk it and and
the other thing is you're still not
fully in control there's a point where
when they look like the immediate danger
was over after a few months a group of
Spartans broke off Santa bond said
that's going to be disaster you're going
to get beaten we're all going to be the
weaker for it but he couldn't force him
to stay he just had to hope they had
learned before they got destroyed and
come to their senses and be a knight
sometimes things are out of your control
and also sadly what it demonstrates this
good no good deed goes unpunished after
he led them through this heroic rescue
he gets word from Athens you're exiled
we don't want you back and so he ended
up in this dais and Sparta King took
pity on him which was good for us became
a farmer and he wrote the histories that
the source of much of what we learned
but going in and persuading you see it
in politics all the time for example
back in the eighties senator from New
Jersey Bill Bradley press a and great
career Democrats are saying you ought to
run first in 88 and then in 1992 and he
said I'm not ready yet when he felt he
was ready in 2000 lost the gore was too
late
Chris Christie New Jersey Governor a lot
of people went to him four years ago and
said he got a run there's a vacuum out
there he said I'm not ready
you should have even though he felt he
wasn't like like Xenophon you just have
to go in life doesn't always go the way
you want it
on the timetable that you think is best
for you you just have to plunge in and
take the risk is he any relation to the
term that we use today xenophobic I
don't know because there's antiphon was
not a non xenophobic right quite the
opposite yeah Athenian learning how to
lead Spartans that's all right so where
where would you put yourself on this
list of leaders that's not about these
ancient leaders like most it would be a
mix Xena fond the importance of
leadership and being able to respond to
changing circumstances one who gets
short shrift from history because the
Greeks wrote it as a Syrus who created
the modern Persian Empire by the
standards of the time I underlined the
word standards of the time verse
he was very tolerant normally in those
days conquerors just came and killed
everybody sold the rest of the slavery
and he in effect take over a place and
say he passed the tribute we leave you
alone so I Jewish historians like Cyrus
he was much more tolerant than some of
the others who ruled them and so again
realizing you can't have it your way or
the highway
I think Augustus in the sense of
recognizing how you step into an unusual
situation and reform he was a great
reformer even after he won the civil
wars he was not a natural-born military
leader he had to step in and cope along
the way but he was smart enough to
recognize too that you don't have to be
flamboyant Julius his uncle Oldman
flamboyance we saw her that lid so even
though he knew he had ultimate power he
always took care to consult work with
people so they wouldn't get natural
accumulation of enemies that somebody
says do this do that like jobs he
learned and he survived he didn't he
didn't die the way his uncle did his
wife killed him at the end
all right last question before we go to
calls and texts and etc z-- some of the
leaders that you speak highly of I think
in power ambition glory include Ray Kroc
Sam Walton Alfred Sloan Henry Ford what
do they have in common what are they why
do they get positive treatments they're
all innovators and reward we obviously
know from the moving assembly line
people forget because he went bankrupt
twice he almost went bankrupt a third
time the model a before he got it right
and it was a sheer determination that
made it happen
the lesson from him was one that
determination is inspiration but also
then he fell into a rut both the Model T
was it an Alfred Sloan put yourself in
his shoes in the early 20s TM nearly
went bankrupt then ramshackle company at
the time Henry Ford at about estimated
50 60 % of the US market nobody could
make a car cheaper than Henry Ford the
Model T getting cheaper and cheaper so
what do you do your company ramshackle
disorganized can't compete on price so
Sloan just changed the rules of the game
he introduced thanks as gifted engineers
introduced the annual model change you
recognize the car just wasn't a
contraption to go from point A to point
B was a reflection of yourself it was a
fashion statement with all the things
that we now take for granted here this
guy looks like an accountant he was
recognized the importance of fashion
annual model trains excitement each year
what what's going to be new in this
model if we mean if he segmented the
market from Chevy to Cadillac he set up
a car for every purse allowing you to
choose color and record said you could
have any color you want as long as it's
black Sloane to let you choose the color
and then buying on time you know today
no ad is complete without you know six
years financing blah blah blah those
days you put the cash up front
Ford thoughts mom is going to destroy
General Motors by allowing people it
wasn't like a house you know car you
could move or wreck that a house you
know you could do a mortgage on that but
the equivalent of mortgage honorably he
thought it was ridiculous Sloan
allows you to put a down payment make
monthly payments and so on a handful of
years a company that was on the ropes
became the dominant auto company even
today will still sell at times more cars
than Toyota General Motors had its own
history they lost sight of the spirit of
Alfred Sloan but Sloan 'la and that
sense was an inspiration and somebody's
dominated in one area you play by lists
by the way politicians show the
Republicans sure to learn about Donald
Trump try to play his game we will beat
you they should have taken inspiration
from Sloan devise your own sandbox
devise your own rules of the game the
only way you can have a chance to win
and then rake rock as an inspiration he
was in his 50s back in the 1950s that's
like being the mid-60s today longevity
never quite hit it in life and so here
he was selling milkshake machines out in
California we're always striving to make
the big hit especially in food never
quite did it long story short he came
across an burger stand McDonald brothers
they had a couple of outlets and he saw
what they didn't see they had
standardized the food business as you
know the restaurant business toughest
business possible it is the highest
casualty rate your inventory is always
going wrong you have to worry about
seeing okay I mean it's in each day you
start a new tough tough business which
is why never had a national chain as
sort of a semi one in the railroad days
but they were always regional like
Howard Johnson's in New England Middle
Atlantic states the National no way just
too complicated business but he realized
they'd standardize the business me so I
get the McDonald brothers to expand even
more I can sell the more milkshake
machines there's a milkshake machine
salesman and he realized this is bigger
than milkshake machines ultimately he
bought them out the rest is history he's
changed established first national and
went went overseas standardized a
business if people thought it couldn't
be done by the way he was one of those
who say stick to your knitting one
though and whenever they come to him say
why don't we go in this area why don't
we go in that area he said can you
guarantee me that every restroom every
McDonald's restaurant is picked
stand clean he said well no well then
we're not going to make go go out of our
realm and so that kind of ability to do
big things and innovate in an area again
seeing what others didn't see Ray Kroc
so if the McDonald brothers did not they
didn't know what they had invented just
as when Steve Jobs went to Menlo Park
and so exert ox researchers had done
with the thing eventually called the
mouse he was he they didn't realize what
they had he did he said oh my god this
is unbelievable
went and developed it and so again it's
not just inventing so you need somebody
who recognizes what the possibilities
are Steve Forbes is our guest callers
you have been very patient Loring and
Huntington New York you're on book TV
please go ahead
hi how are you can you you hear me okay
we have listening sir I'm interested in
your view how you view the union
movement in this country it's very
influential still and can can or do they
help or interfere with your kind of
reform proposals what are you learning
what's your view of the Union I think
they're necessary but they seem to
interfere with a lot of things
thank you sir Steve Forbes I think first
you have to make the distinction between
traditional what we used to call
industrial unions and government worker
unions two very different things
the government workers unions have
gotten a lot of power and because in
effect they negotiate with themselves
the politicians know many of them that
they're dependent on their support we've
gotten the situation where pension
systems have not been not been properly
funded on the industrial side the very
prosperity of the US especially since
the depression union membership has
declined very sharply and sometimes many
times they've gotten in the way of their
companies that their whose workers they
represent from making
Cerie change the classic cases Detroit
back in the 1970s when the Japanese 80s
when the Japanese decided and other
foreign companies decide to put
facilities manufacturing facilities in
the US they first went in the Michigan
Midwest area because that's where the
infrastructure was for the auto industry
and they went to the UAW United Auto
Workers and said we want to set up shop
here a set up factories however your
work rules especially the Japanese said
we Honda led the way
so we can't work with these they won't
work with us and so we we need a change
in the work rules the UAW said no way
we're not going well you're going to
have the same work rules as the others
stifling work rules so Honda first did a
facility for motorcycles in the Ohio
non-union and then the other
manufacturers came in and put in
facilities in what they call
right-to-work states we didn't have
unions and they flourished in Detroit
though we saw what happened to them
several years ago so the unions didn't
respond in this case to a very change
circumstances they're stuck in the past
and it hurt and by the way sometimes
union leaders it's not just politicians
are out of touch with their constituents
as a union in the Northeast called the
Communication Workers of America they're
very big in government unions but they
also still represent they just had to
strike with the Verizon and where the ch
CWA workers union leaders were in favor
of Bernie Sanders but astonishingly a
good portion of their rank-and-file US
government workers but their industrial
workers were are in favor of least we're
in favor of Donald Trump
they were quite startled by it well
there is a book that you wrote with your
picture on the front it came out in 2005
it's called flat tax revolution I think
you know what I'm going to show here but
it's the blurb on the top of the book a
must read by anyone interested in the
future of this country Donald J Trump
see a friend of yours I've known him for
30 years
back in the 80s when he for
first on the real-estate scene in New
York and I was hoping he would go with
the flat tax in the campaign he came up
with a tax plan needs some tweaking not
bad but wasn't a flat tax so it was
persuasive but not persuasive enough
have you endorsed him the I made clear
that if he's the Republican nominee yes
I will back him who were you supporting
in the primary none was like the dating
game I'd find the pieces of this that
candidate that I liked but none ever put
it together as we were discussing
earlier I was shocked that the many of
these people did not lead with something
like the flat tax or something big in
health care I mean not to pick on
because everyone did Jeb Bush was a
sensational governor of Florida came up
with the theme we need more economic
growth yeah right
he said four percent we need four
percent GDP growth I understood what he
was saying we say four percent GDP
growth it sounds like a hair formula
Rogaine with four percent GDP you know
great they never gave people a takeaway
never gave people what they call
marketing deliverable how this is going
to better in the country how this is
going to better you the way Reagan did
in 1980 wasn't just Reagan was a very
smooth speaker all that kind of thing he
had substance he knew how to put it in a
way that people would say yes I get it
he understood how to communicate and by
the way even though we all worship Him
great man Abraham Lincoln you can learn
from how he try to persuade people who
on certain issues were not very much in
favor initially where he was coming from
how you bring people along and he
learned that because he was a an
attorney and always had to convince
juries how do I get the point across
juries how do I bring people along so
he'd always start with something small
and then bring them all brink try to
bring them along understanding sometimes
they're not going to come along but
bringing people along Reagan understood
it I mean most of these candidates did
not
I think people still yearn for that and
here's a text message that came in for
you came in from Detroit I think three
one three area code
how can a Republican president create
changes that would be more favorable to
the economy than a democratic new
president because taking Bernie Sanders
and a lesser extent Hillary Clinton
choose Bernie Sanders light they both
want to raise taxes substantially that
is going to be a disaster they want to
have more government involvement in
health care that is a disaster and huge
missed opportunity for really unleashing
great new innovations in health care and
that better coverage for everybody they
don't understand the fed and so on the
Republican side Ted Cruz I know he's
dropped out was pre coming very good on
the need to reform the fed Donald Trump
has made some comments on it so maybe
he'll have elaborate down on more but I
think Trump understands we'll see how he
articulates it the need for fundamental
tax reform need for fundamental reform
and regulation when you talk about
regulatory reform people tend to think
that means you're an anarchist you want
to throw them all away know what what
you're doing what you're doing is trying
to come up with sensible common-sense
rules of the road not telling you what
to drive where to drive and things like
that now we have a dedicated number set
aside for text messages text messages
only not for phone calls and if you
would if you do send a text please
include at least your name and your city
so we can identify you that way
Frida is calling in from Little Rock
Arkansas Freda you're on with author
journalist Steve Forbes thank you for
taking my call let me just say that I am
disappointed in you mr. Forbes for not
backing fully Ted Cruz he was the only
constitutional candidate that you had
and he backed capitalism quite a bit he
thought of your flat tax and
just as his tax plan according to you
and he adopted some of your ideas why
did you stay neutral our country is at
stake here and yet all the people that
are conservative and yourself stay
neutral
all right Frieda we got your question
let's hear from mr. Ford's Wilfried on
and turn terms of a Ted Cruz he did have
some interesting good ideas on the on
the flat tax but it was very late in the
day before he put it out there and led
with it and in terms of in terms same
thing with the with the Federal Reserve
he started to get it I talked to him
about it but he didn't lead with it and
you got to come out front on these
things and he didn't do the way we're
discussing in terms of making these
clear in a way that people could
immediately grasp you say
constitutionalists I understand what
you're saying about the Constitution I
think by the way Ted Cruz should be a
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court or at
least as associate justice some day he'd
be superb he understands that document
in a way that few others do in the
history behind it but he didn't go out
there and and the lead the way that
Reagan did and so I was almost there for
him but he didn't close until almost the
end when it was when it was too late
and that's why when all the other
candidates fell by the wayside
most of them except for Governor Kasich
Cruz hadn't established that Reagan
identity in terms of these issues like
the flat tax or healthcare having
patients control health care and so he
wasn't he
Trump was able to beat him because Cruz
hadn't established it the way Trump did
with issues like immigration and the 45%
sales taxes on imports will you be
attending the convention mr. Ford's in
Cleveland
I haven't attended a convention in 20
years well since I did it for 30 years
tended everyone so wasn't much new to
see I thought
I thought I got more sometimes like
watching a football game in the midst of
winter you see more on the screen you
see spending others talks and others and
all the networks are out there covering
the thing and so I thought instead of
being swirling around rumors I'd have
people like you ferret out what was
happening well actually in this age of
social media what do you remember about
conventions in the earlier days did you
enjoy them yes because before I first
when I attended was 1964 the Goldwater
convention the Cow Palace which is no
longer around in San Francisco and back
then they hadn't mastered television so
the speeches were awfully boring but
they were authentic they allowed for
demonstrations and people behaved in
ways that they'd never do rarely would
do today on TV where these things maybe
the Democrats will be different this
year where everything is choreographed
down to you know where where you sit and
what you wear and when you smile and
when you don't and in 64 was very
raucous and raw gold water rights are
taking over the so-called Eastern
establishment been defeated and there
was no love lost between them and I'll
never forget being there watching Nelson
Rockefeller governor of New York on
successful candidate make a speech went
up with his wife second wife and in
those days we forget today divorce was a
huge huge issue for more than today here
he came with a second wife and the
convention most of the delegates from
Goldwater guys booed and it wasn't just
boo it was you look at their faces this
was the representative of the devil the
devil would have gotten a better
reception than Nelson and the raucous
was screaming and oh my wow that is
amazing
and but that was a kind of a raw emotion
you would see at a convention and things
would happen
68 enough said Chicago riots in the
street as the convention was going on
Mayor Daley you wouldn't do it today
and he obviously passed away but where
he and effect said some choice words lip
readers could see it when River coughed
senator rubyconf of Connecticut was
speaking you don't see very much of that
the last convention we had even a semi
contest was 1976 in Kansas City between
Reagan and Gerald Ford but even there we
sort of everyone sort of knew Ford had
the slight edge was not going to be a
landslide with a slight edge and the
only really totally unscripted thing was
after Ford got the nomination was going
to accept the nomination he called
Reagan down to say a few words from the
stands from from from Reagan was up in
the audience he'd lost and Reagan
finally persuaded Reagan to come down
and say a few words and Reagan said some
words probably from the speech he was
going to give him he got in the
nomination you can see people saying men
do we make the right choice here because
he was so good and and and then in 1980
the excitement real last bit of
excitement was a the one looked like
Reagan might try to have Gerald Ford was
the next president become his running
mate for vice president up sort of a Co
presidency so for several hours that was
swirling around before Reagan picked
George HW Bush those moments are rare
and more and more it's become a festive
that's why the Democrats have their
super-delegates since the conventions a
coronation why not make sure that their
thinking was you have all these elected
officials who might not have made it
through the primary process because they
backed the wrong candidate but we want
them there unite the party and all that
kind of thing that's right there are
super-delegates not to rigged it
normally decisions already been made and
here we have a year where you could
still come up with a scenario I wrote
about it the other day where Joe Biden
could end up with the nomination this
year has broken all the norms so maybe I
should have gone but I'll watch you guys
do it well we have a picture of you
at a younger age visiting with a US
president can you tell us what we're
looking at here that is with my father
and mother my siblings we are visiting
President Eisenhower my father was this
is 1957 which one are you I'm the one
right next to the baby with my mother
holding my sister Moira she's about a
year and a half and we were visiting
Eisenhower he's giving this blessing to
my father's candidacy
so I remember Bembridge there's the
governor of New Jersey and remembered
vividly and Ike gave us presents he gave
us each a pen so that was a big deal you
still have it yes
maybe it's my only 401k you know and I
wasn't a perfed but well for a kid it
was exciting
going to the White House Eisenhower was
not just a president he was the man who
will help when World War Two and so it's
quite exciting and but it was also a
good political lesson even though he's
endorsed by I can Vice President Nixon
came and to help my father he's lost my
father said he was nosed out by a
landslide and endorsements endorsements
are nice but they don't always sway
voters now we're going to show another
picture here who is in this picture mr.
Forbes do you recognize that picture at
all yes it's uh oh wow how young I
looked my father and my mother brothers
they make it a little larger yeah
there's and that's you next to your
father
that's me next to my father and there's
more of me now and less hair and who are
your three brothers
Christopher Kip we call him Bob and Tim
and each amazing the skin shows the
futility of social engineering here we
are brought in the same household and
same parents and each of us very
different for just one example my
brother Tim
is big still you know he's in the 60s on
mountain climbing he does ice climbing
I think it's nuts but he actually enjoys
it and I'll never forget several years
ago we are in Wyoming where he has a
place he lives in Wyoming now and and
they decided to climb on the Tetons and
so he went with his daughter they went
up at 1 a.m. in the morning that's what
you do and spend a day climbing up and
down and at the end of the day late
afternoon he comes back you know full of
him and vigor and she is limping she's
in bad shape could barely move and take
days to recover and she said and he does
this for fun excuse what's the matter of
this guy well so some more pictures as
we go this afternoon on book TV but Jeff
and Fresno thanks for holding you're on
with Steve Forbes here's mr. Forbes ah
in my adult life it's mixing I don't
remember any Republican President or any
Republican legislator ever doing
anything to try to bring health care to
all Americans now don't get me wrong I
don't believe in socialized medicine but
why not modify Obamacare as opposed to
repeal completely the the reason for
starting like the tax code
semia new with Obamacare is that the the
thing is just not working for example
the individual mandate an expert to work
for the government the other day told me
he said we've effectively exempted
two-thirds of the individuals from from
the mandate because the thing just
wasn't going to work was going to be
politically unpopular to require it
expenses are still going up the
exchanges are not working very well for
example many of these bronze plans even
though they subsidize the premiums the
deductibles are horrible so people may
have insurance but they're discovering
that their out-of-pocket costs are
higher than they were before
so rather than
try to amend Obamacare I think we should
move more in the direction of reforms
such as nationwide shopping for health
insurance right now every state has
their own rules you have these state
cartels I live in New Jersey even before
Obamacare New Jersey's regulations were
crazy I could get a perfectly good
health insurance policy neighboring
Pennsylvania at a fraction of the cost
of New Jersey but it was illegal for me
to do it I could buy a neck time
Pennsylvania but not the insurance so
let's have nationwide shopping and how
about transparency they could do this
tomorrow what am i repealing Obamacare
I'm not I want to enhance the the
availability of health care but in terms
of getting consumer control why not
mandate that hospitals and clinics post
prices for all their treatments and
services and so if one Hospital charges
two thousand dollars for an MRI another
one says we'll do it for 350 you as a
consumer can say okay let's look at that
or how about requiring hospitals to post
each month how many patients die from
infections received after they went to
the hospital it's a national scandal
Chipotle the food you know any
restaurant gets food poisoning it's a
national story thankfully no one died in
that case but tens of thousands of
patients died unnecessarily from
infections received after they'd been to
the hospital page people don't know that
that should be public information so and
you should be able to choose your own
health insurance policy instead of what
the government says you should have I
don't need help
I don't need pregnancy services we
should be able to choose what needs our
meats are particularly tanned so those
are the kinds of reforms we outline in
the book that would be very positive and
have more effective like we have with
food more effective safety nets more
health care more affordable health care
and you see little snippets of it you
see little snippets of what can come for
example of surgery on the eyes LASIK
surgery on the eyes so you might not
have to where these things cost about
half or in real terms a fraction of what
it did 15 years ago
why because you don't have the
disconnect between providers and
consumers so providers have every
incentive to make it more affordable for
you more attractive for you we note our
publisher and in book the reviving
America rich Carl guard who said about
12 years ago he got it done for five
thousand he said I could get it done
today for twenty five hundred perhaps
I've even a better result so we want
that in all of healthcare more for less
cosmetic surgery has grown Sevenfold in
20 years but unless it's a result of
disease or accident it's between you and
the provider so you scope it out like
anything else so you haven't had the
wild inflation though that you've had
elsewhere so we're trying to get the
best of all worlds instead of a system
where they're going to have more and
more rationing and I'll just give you
one example I know I'm going on but this
this is critical one of the virtues of
free markets is that it gets information
out very quickly when something works
everyone quickly imitates when Apple
came along with iPads and iPhones
Samsung and others not long after would
come up with their version say our
products better you don't find that in
health care takes years for things to go
through one example breast cancer though
you're told a certain age of your woman
get to get the mammogram do you realize
that if you have dense tissue mammograms
have a very hard time detecting that
cancer they oh they only get at about 30
40 50 percent of the time and but
there's a new way of doing it called MBI
it's called I think metabolism of breast
imaging and I'll get the name here
because it's important and seeing we
have here I'll find it in oh yeah
Molecular breast imaging MBI look it up
Molecular breast imaging it comes from
the Mayo Clinic is the one pushing it so
it's a highly reputable institution NBI
so if you or your spouse or friends or
whatever
female tell them to get the NBI it is
lightyears ahead in terms of detecting
breast cancer if you have dense tissue
and why when we have more publicity on
that
because we have this top-down system and
so critical information doesn't get
expanded as rapidly as it would in a
normal free market so these are truly
life-and-death decisions and that's why
I don't want more of the same or trying
to improve what we have now I want more
where the providers know they have to
satisfy you the patient and when you're
in charge I guarantee you it'll be a
very different experience not perfect as
we're human but it'll be far better than
the experiences you have today when you
go to a hospital and Joseph in Santa
Barbara please go ahead with your
question or comment for Steve forms good
morning
took me three years to get on and I'm
happy to be here and mr. Forbes I'm
happy to have you there I'd like to
first I'm a registered independent of 70
in my 70s and I've been watching a few
stands since the very beginning what my
concern is and I'd like to get your
opinion on a solution is that we have a
situation where and our Congress makes
the law but when it comes to the
rulemaking and regulations that is done
by unelected unelected bureaucrats right
and problem I see there is of course
they are mainly primarily liberal
they're protected from being firing and
it doesn't matter who what
administration is whether it's
Republican Democrat they continue to
exist so it's almost like a fourth part
of our government which is not in the
Constitution so that concerns me and I
don't know what we can do about it and I
don't see a lot of talk about let's
listen to Steve Forbes and see what he
has to say Joseph in Santa Barbara
thanks for watching and I'm glad you got
through Thank You Joseph you bring up
something critically important
and that is most of the effective laws
today are not made by Congress they're
made by these agencies and government
departments in 2014 for example I think
Congress passed 115 114 laws agencies
passed the equivalent of 3400 laws
regulations of the force of federal law
and three thousand others in the works
and too often these rules and regs are
made based on more ideology and whim
rather than science trying to fight them
very difficult and people don't know
we're discussing earlier in the show
people don't know they're committing
felonies for example show how crazy it
is if you go on a federal land you're
walking your dog if your leash is longer
than six feet you're committing a crime
now put aside whether they should be
regulating the length of leashes but
making it a federal crime is absolutely
preposterous and the code is littered
with this stuff on the adjuster in the
federal code alone 5,000 of laws they
think they can't even count them all and
from the regulatory agencies which you
talk about 300,000 and so one step in
the right direction senator Hatch of
Utah is pushing this as a number of
people in the house and the house that
have got bipartisan support for it they
haven't gotten in the Senate yet is put
in amplified what they call mens rhea
latin for guilty mind in other words if
you don't know that you're committing a
felony when you have a long leash when
you go on a federal parkland they can't
throw you in jail and so you have to
know that you're committing a crime
before they can can do it that in
essence is a reform that senator hatch
and others want to put in this new crime
bill they've been discussing in Congress
that would go a long ways to this
arbitrary situation where rules are
written in vague language so it's up to
the bureaucracy to interpret what they
really mean it goes against the rule of
law the rule of law is based on you know
what the rules of the game are and if
you violate them you know you're going
to pay a price
them today is that the book by Harvey
silverglade three felonies a day that
that that that is all too true the Uncle
Sam wants to get you he can we should
change Uncle Sam's name to Uncle tyrant
in that sense so the hacks reform would
be a superb step in the right direction
and then too there are a number of
institutions I was at a dinner the other
night for the Competitive Enterprise
Institute that are fighting legally
these excesses and pushing legislation
for example on the regulation that cost
more than a hundred million dollars a
year Congress must vote it up or down it
just can't say oh that's out of our
hands they have to take electoral
responsibility for it so I think people
need to learn more about how dangerous
this situation is and reforms like the
hatch reform or some of these other
bills that give the citizen more power
and more accountability to our elected
officials so they can't hide behind the
regulatory state all those would be good
steps in the right direction and from
his book freedom manifesto Steve Forbes
writes regulatory violations are
increasingly being treated as criminal
offenses by federal bureaucracies that
are increasingly resorting to the use of
force Joe is in Lakewood Colorado Joe
good afternoon good afternoon and good
afternoon mr. Forbes and thank you for
having number easy and thank you book
for TV for hosting him I've enjoyed your
insights and I was wondering about your
position on getting health care through
your employer you sounds like you didn't
see that as a good thing and my
experience is that when my company
downsized I lost my job and I was paying
$13,000 a year on Cobra but when I sort
insurance elsewhere I found that it
would cost seventeen to twenty two
thousand dollars a year because I was
grouped in an over 55 year old insurance
risk pool and the company based wrists
pulled out for better coverage in price
and as a consumer that sounds like a
better option and I was wondering what
problems if any you saw with
employer-based insurance plans since I
wasn't able to find better cheaper plans
and should we be looking more towards
the original Blue Cross Blue Shield
model of nonprofit health insurance
thank you
a interesting question and that and that
is a couple of things you touch on one
reason why employer based and by the way
an employer wants to provide health
insurance I'm all for it we think of the
way we do it is a very attractive for
getting and keeping good people and but
one of the one of the challenges is that
you you mentioned you had Cobra which
was very expensive but because of the
tax situation if you're an employer or
self-employed you get to deduct your
premiums which effectively reduces the
cost quite a bit if you're just an
individual who either is wants to change
jobs or lost a job and has to go on
Cobra you go on the individual market
you have to pay with after-tax dollars
so already when you go out there you're
30 40 50 percent behind not that's got
to change another thing is that since
the markets are all geared now for
employers and third parties I think what
the changes we're talking about you'll
get the development of an individual
market and one of the reforms we have to
make is to make it feasible and easier
when you leave an employer you own the
insurance policy and and if it costs
13,000 you pay 13,000 it's not 17 or 22
or 32 and have to go on these exchanges
where you have a 50 thousand dollar
deductible and you have to go to
specialist five hundred miles away that
that's the kind of system we have to
change and those changes are very
feasible and I think when again when
hospitals and clinics know that you the
individual actually controls the dollars
not the employer employers too often and
we're sort of guilty of it we try to do
our best it's sort of one size fits all
we offer a policy and we think it's a
good one especially that $2,500 we give
you two to meet the deductible cash you
may you may conclude that doesn't fit
your particular needs
each and
vigil has particular needs and you
should be able to choose what meets your
needs not what an employer thinks so we
want a true market you get it through
the employer you can get it through your
union you can get through an association
or fraternal order or whatever or an
individual market just like you do with
the homeowners insurance or car
insurance I want that kind of
competition where Flo and others and
that Geico thing whatever you call them
are of saying we we got something better
for you we can do it cheaper for you
that's the kind of competition I want
and so I want you to control those
dollars and by the way just one thing on
this because of the the the system we
have again nobody designed it people
don't realize how much they actually pay
for health insurance
not just deductibles and co-pays it's
also the taxes you pay to the federal
government to finance Medicare the tax
you pay the federal government to
finance their portion of Medicaid the
taxes you paid to state governments to
financially their portion of Medicaid
the salary that you might have lost
because the company has to buy the
health insurance that could have gone to
you in terms of salary it adds up to one
over your lifetime over your lifetime
without you even knowing it you
effectively spend 1.9 million dollars on
health care and most people have no idea
what the true price of what they're
paying is now for every author we have
on in depth on book TV we ask him or her
for the books they're currently reading
some of the books that are important to
them their influences here are some of
Steve Forbes answers and if you're on
the line stay on the line because we
will be coming back to take your calls
[Music]
here's a look at some authors recently
featured on book TVs afterwards our
weekly author interview program demos
vice-president of policy and research
Tamara droughts talked about America's
new working class and their potential
political power and Chaka sin Gore
weighed in on criminal justice reform
and recalled his 19 years in prison
Iran Institute Fellow Don Watkins argued
that measures to alleviate income
inequality actually end up hurting
low-income Americans in the coming weeks
on afterward Senator Barbara Boxer of
California looks back at her life and
career in politics
Natalia hope profiles the women
instrumental in the development of
America's space program in the 1940s and
50s and this weekend Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell talks about his
political philosophy and how its
informed his time in the Senate he talks
with Senator Lamar Alexander I think
divided government is probably the only
time you can do big transformative
things give you a for example Reagan and
Tip O'Neill raise the age for Social
Security Reagan and Tip O'Neill did the
last comprehensive tax reform
Bill Clinton a Republican Congress did
welfare reform and actually balanced the
budget
three years in a row big stuff arguably
none of that could have been done in
unified government afterwards airs on
book TV every Saturday at 10:00 p.m. and
Sunday at 9:00 p.m. Eastern you can
watch all previous afterwards programs
on our website book TV org
[Music]
and
by
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
and Steve Forbes you list is one of your
influences Alexander Hamilton here's a
quote from your book money in
remembrance of Alexander Hamilton like
few others before or since he showed
that money properly understood is the
root of all good yes when he became
Treasury secretary the US was junk bond
nation our debts were a shambles our
finances were a shambles he had studied
the Bank of England he had studied how
Britain smaller than France because as
did its finances right was able to beat
the French Empire and so he wanted to
take some of those basic principles here
one of them was he realized the need for
a stable value for money so he fixed the
dollar to gold he instituted a revenue
system for the federal government so
would have a reliable source of revenue
he took over state debts because he
wanted debt holders around the country
to have a stake in the success of this
new new enterprise so he took the
shambles of the the debt situation from
the Revolutionary War rationalized it
and he established the mint he got a
system of finance going that it was
critical and is underappreciated by
historians maybe the play Hamilton will
get people look at Hamilton again in a
more serious way of a critical reason
why we went from the small East Coast
nation largely farming to the -
industrial nation in the world and
within a hundred years extraordinary
even more impressive than what Britain
did and Hamilton put the system in that
made that possible and we take it for
granted
have you seen Hamilton on Broadway I
haven't I'm probably about three years
before I get a ticket but they're hard
to get both - OH - is the area code if
you want to continue in our conversation
with Steve Forbes today we're going to
put the phone lines up we're going to
put the social media addresses up and
we're going to put up the text address
now this is for text messages only and
it is five one zero three four zero five
five five nine that again is for text
messages only if you would like to send
one
please include your first name in your
city so we can identify you that way
that would be great and I do want to go
to a text message that we've been
holding here and this is from Scott and
wilkes-barre Pennsylvania mr. Forbes
would you consider a cabinet position in
the Trump White House specifically
Secretary of the Treasury the answer is
of any president cause you take the call
and it's not likely to happen for a
whole variety of reasons but I'm glad he
thinks Scott thinks that I would be
qualified and get the call but the key
thing is to make sure the ideas are
right and the key thing to is whoever as
president not only understands it but
will make clear to his or her staff
don't get in the way of the reforms that
are needed one of the veins of the
cabinet secretary ships today and it
really frustrates governors is when you
come in you find out presents just not
your boss it's just not going to Capitol
Hill you have these all these White
House staffers who think they know more
than you do and don't mind trying to
show how smart they are by micromanaging
you so you got to set out the rules in
advance but whoever's present whether
it's Donald Trump and his head today
which can change but whoever it is I'll
be sending my ideas even though I'm a
Scotsman I'll send them a free copy of
my book why do you say it would not
happen for a variety of reasons one
they're a whole whole calculus of
decisions of the factors that go into
picking a cabinet member
have you taken care of certain parts of
the country certain parts of the party
certain area groups that you want to
show that you're attentive to and so or
there may be a headline about some
crisis in Asia so you might want
somebody was a recognized expert in a
whole variety of things and it's not
just one post it's a number of posts
that go into this thing when you read
how it's the chemistry is actually done
it's kind of a help to skelter thing
it's a partly science at the beginning
they say we'll come up with 10 names and
blah blah blah blah
and then at the end they say well this
person might be good but we have to use
political capital to get him or her
through Congress going through the
Senate and even though they might be
good maybe we should save our political
capital for something else so no I'm
keeping my day job for now Raymond and
Tyler Texas please go ahead with your
question for Steve Forbes thank you
Steve and Raymond Trowbridge in Tyler
Texas my question is on the gold
standard the ghost the gold is a solid
currency is it with in regard to keeping
our sovereignty as a nation and having a
solid currency that is impenetrable by
other nations and it is a standard going
along with Gresham's law of economics
bad currency drives out good currency
when we got off the gold standard
we established bad currency that's just
my opinion
now when others countries go up in
currency you know valuing or whatever it
hammers us so we had same wall of
punishment that they're getting but it
affects everybody here in our country
every citizen the law doesn't respect
personality it's solid either we can
form by an act of our will to have
something stable like what's going on
now in the government honesty okay
honesty is can be considered a currency
of exchange as well hey Raymond could
you wrap this up and we'll get a
response yes and is a currency and it
doesn't choose sides
so to wrap it up the thing what
principle we need to get back to the
basics that we yield to and go ahead I'm
through thank you and the key is having
currency with a stable value like
Alexander Hamilton recognized more than
the two
fifteen years ago and he fix it the goal
just as the British Pound at the time
was fixed to gold and that's a critical
reason why we had this great growth that
we had and we discussed earlier we had a
gold standard for one hundred and eighty
years and it worked we had the greatest
growth of any nation in history a lot of
factors other factors at work but we got
the money right and since we've been off
the gold standard our average growth
rate has been far lower than it was when
we are on it averaged over time and with
our economy today if we'd had the same
growth we had when we were on gold we'd
be eight trillion dollars bigger economy
today over 40 years compounding hurts
because investing is risky if you don't
know what you're going to get paid back
in you get less productive investing and
when you had a fixed value for the
dollar guess what happened you had less
currency trading you didn't need it you
know when you go from Texas to Oklahoma
you don't have to worry about what the
dollar is worth in Oklahoma versus Texas
it's the same currency today of having
this all these floating currencies
currency trading on a daily basis is 5.3
trillion dollars more than stocks and
bonds put together tens of thousands of
the best minds in the world focus on
trying to make money trading currencies
huge waste of resources huge waste of
brain power that's why we got to get
back to a gold standard and also you hit
you hit the word trust Trust is what
makes a currency work and when you lose
trust then at least all sorts of social
problems and Justins you have 12 inches
in a foot or 60 minutes an hour to have
a stable currency would make life a lot
better than what we've been going
through well here's a text message from
Northern Virginia what is your thought
on Bitcoin Bitcoin the challengeable
Bitcoin rose up you might call it a
high-tech cry for help
these and other cryptocurrency
rose up because of a lack of faith in
the dollar and a sense of wanting
privacy the challenge with Bitcoin as I
see it is that it's still unstable and
value let's say you got paid in bitcoins
one week you could buy a probably a Kobe
beef or steaks next we could probably
get the second rate hamburger because of
its so volatile so they got to find a
way to stabilize it but what is coming
out of these crypto currencies like
Bitcoin is I think a new payment system
we don't realize how expensive and
complicated our whole banking finance
payment system is today we think we're
going to go to the store we swipe our
card boy isn't that magic yeah it is but
you ask a merchant why do I have to pay
three to six percent for that card swipe
so what bitcoin is showing is you can do
this for a fraction of these this
payment system of what we have today not
good news for some of the credit cards
not good news for American Express and
in terms of electronic banking one of
the countries that leads the world in
electronic banking because they have to
they have no choice is Kenya handhelds
because they can't have a traditional
system and so here technology may come
to the rescue not only in the cost of
transactions but for developing
countries
just as tell handheld devices in terms
of telephones you didn't have to have
all these telephone poles and all the
old traditional infrastructure you could
get all around that with these handheld
telephones
handheld devices so two on banking you
may not have to have all the
infrastructure we have today you're
already seeing online lenders beginning
to emerge who can do it at a fraction of
the cost and far more efficiently than
the traditional system so if you're in
banking it's not just government
regulation that's killing you the web
may do to you what it did to the print
industry well in your book freedom
manifesto we're taught in grade school
that Thomas Edison invented the
incandescent bulb because he wanted to
create better light
pure false he always wanted to do things
better but what this goes to show is
that human emotions are there and the
key thing is to channel them in a
productive direction Thomas Edison was
mad at the gas man in those days gas was
the chief source of illumination and he
being an entrepreneur was always falling
behind in his bills and we have a note
my grandfather back in 1920 sent Edison
the note about is this legend about why
you invented the incandescent light bulb
was true and Edison wrote back to my
father he said yes an essence is true he
said I was paying a sheriff five dollars
a day to postpone a judgment on my small
factory then came the gas man he cut off
my gas that made me so mad that it read
up on gas techniques and technology see
of electricity couldn't be made to
replace gas he said I stuck to it
but I didn't hurt them at all except
lately 40 years so his anger at the gas
man that had Edison go for the
incandescent light bulb and electricity
to replace traditional gas so when you
get angry think of how can I make money
off of this Joe's in Carmel Indiana hi
Joe hi Steven I'd like to hear your
critique of the Fair Tax and of whether
you think Donald Trump would be opposed
to the Fair Tax because it would hit big
real estate projects so hard in terms of
the fair taxes it's a national sales tax
we discuss it extensively in the book
several pages the effective rate is not
the advertised 23 we explain why the
real rate is 30% so if you go in a store
and buy something for $100 you're going
to pay a $30 sales tax on it and it's
meant to replace the income tax and the
payroll tax and the primarily but the
challenge with the with the national
sales tax is several fold one is just
political when you say a 30% rate people
just recoil you can talk about embedded
prices all you want they just
think oh my god I'm going to want to buy
a new house and have to pay a 30% tax
yes you will and so that's a challenge
another challenge which is also very
important is the 16th amendment to the
Constitution 16th amendment allows
Washington to impose an income tax if
you don't repeal the 16th amendment to
the Constitution I guarantee you you'll
eventually have as you have in most
countries and most states both an income
tax and a sales tax like in Europe they
have high income taxes and they have
what they call a value-added tax which
is sort of a sales tax and so you got to
repeal the 16th amendment then you have
the challenge of compliance it's one
thing to put a tax on a product but what
about services when you get high rates
then people have a huge incentive to get
around that kid comes and cuts your lawn
you're going to pay a 30% tax on that I
don't think so
we've talked about the the Fair Tax says
they'll put their thirty percent tax on
a new house but not on an existing house
well then you get in a problem defining
what is new and what is a traditional
house let's say take a traditional house
you've got the thing to keep the facade
maybe and redo the whole thing there's a
thirty percent sales tax apply to that
so you're going to have to deal with
these zoning of particular questions and
then who collects the tax if they're tax
people the sales tax people say they
want the states to collect it but
they're only going to pay the state's
one quarter of one percent to a
collective thing not much of an
incentive the state will make sure they
get their tax but they don't care about
Uncle Sam and so you take the 30 percent
rate you combine it with some states
like California get a to 10 percent
people just think 38 40 percent sales
tax very very hard sell and you have the
definition problem you have the
definition of for example in the sales
tax if you buy something for your
business you don't pay the sales tax
that's what the fair tax people say so
let's say I go to a home depot buy some
lumber say I'm using it to build
furniture for from
my business well who's going to check to
make sure you just didn't do it for your
own home improvement and you use it to
sell something online so you have real
thorny compliance problems you can
probably get around these but I want
change now now flat tax has already been
done around the world we can do it
quickly
maybe a fair tax can be done with
education than the next generation but
we need action now so someone let's go
out and buy your book which of your
books would you recommend well all of
them they make great you don't have to
go to college you just get these books I
think in terms of the political season
of the reviving America explains in a
very straightforward way three big
things that need to be done and we've
got to get these issues out there not
just in this election season but next
year in the federal level and also on
the state level and healthcare you know
it's 20% of our economy it's the most
personal thing possible it affects all
of us clearly it's not working and the
the I whole idea and this is where the
candidates still you can turn what looks
like a hopeless complicated mess where
the bureaucrats always seem to be
playing whack-a-mole to get a problem
here whack it comes up there whack whack
whack into something dynamic like high
tech when we all come out ahead this is
exciting stuff from your book money what
kind of society sells a lifelong burden
of indebtedness to people inexperienced
with money who are at the beginning of
their working lives
you mentioned Collins well we all now
it's even two three years ago college
debt was just beginning to emerge as an
issue but now it's well over a trillion
dollars and one of the things that has
happened with all good intentions is
that as costs went up government came in
subsidized loans Pell grants and the
like and what did it end up doing it end
up raising tuitions and so you're on a
vicious cycle
you look at the growth of administrative
costs at these institutions why they
going that's always a telltale sign when
that goes up faster than teaching actual
real laboratory research real scholarly
research and so the there's a lot of
bloat out there a lot of nice big
buildings and swimming pools very nice
but not the essence of learning and so
the students end up coming out of
college many case especially graduate
school where you really see it where you
have a mini mortgage and no house to
show for it and right now because of
these mistakes we would make have a pump
job market and so the prospects of being
able to get this off your back in a few
years
keep received in the environment and
then the government has incentives where
if you work in government you get a
faster payoff forgiveness than if you
work producing things in the private
sector which is bizarre you know we want
people to produce things so it's bad all
around and by the way it can be done in
terms of controlling costs I think
parents are beginning to wake up to this
just showing the other day of the
president Purdue University only invest
annuals who has huge experience in this
town on budgeting he successful
executive in the private sector very
successful governor where he turned a
state that was in trouble into the
triple-a credit Midwest no energy no
high-tech real hard work because he's
been able to put in systems and ruin
control expenses I think for almost five
years now they've had no tuition
increases if you look at the nominal
tuitions at schools now most of them are
sixty plus thousand Purdue it's still 48
and when he first put in the policy no
more tuition increases tells the story
the admissions department said this will
hurt us attracting students he said what
do you mean if our of our price is less
than others people are going to think
we're an inferior institution because
why are we cheaper must be we're not as
good now it's the opposite they say can
we say again there's going to be no
tuition increase because a lot of
if we want to get who really loved the
idea only paying 48 can hit with 48
instead of 60 or 65 so and he also makes
a very good point this again gets to
we've got to get pressure from parents
and others he said you should don't go
in these institutions or anything and
think you can just take a meat axe and
cut off a lot of fat he said a better
analogy is that the fat is marbled
throughout the animal and so you haven't
get you have to get people inside to
work with you put incentives inside to
cut out these unnecessary costs but over
time it adds up that's the model Purdue
well mr. Forbes you're the father of
five daughters
have you figured out how much you've
spent for college education I don't want
to know and but yeah and but the thing
is you parents want to do it but I think
now I propose of that initial admissions
Department response to mitch Daniels
president Daniels is that parents are
now saying more and more what are we
getting for this money what are you
getting as a student and one of the and
that this leads to pushing kids to do
more economics more business but you
also still want to have a system where
they can do the humanities Steve Jobs
understood humanities and Sciences are
not polar opposites each reinforce the
other they're intermingled like that
marbling in in the animal and norman
borlaug the famous a Nobel Prize died
several years ago but he created the
Green Revolution which saved hundreds
and millions of people around the world
from famine in India and elsewhere huge
advances and seeds and he so he made
Johnny was in chemistry or whatever in
college and I remember him hearing and
give an address to students of
graduation 20 years ago and he said to
students he said don't specialize too
early or if you do make sure you take
courses outside your comfort zone
because he said you never know what you
might need to draw on and lie
when he made the start to make the
breakthrough in the Green Revolution he
said I needed new love bad economics
which I didn't study very much I need to
know about politics all these things
that were outside my immediate sphere
I had a groan so see it as a way of
exercising the mind and one thing Purdue
does I think I get this rice they
Daniels discovered when he went there
they had core curriculum but it had 363
courses like ceramics he supposes doing
here so what he did what they did is put
together which my call a package of
courses so you take real humanities
courses because most of the kids who go
they're engineers one can go into a
major an engineering one sort or another
but there's an incentive of taking this
package instead of picking a course here
because it might be easy or you know you
have to go to class on Saturday or
Sunday whatever if you take that package
you get a certificate not just a diploma
of a certificate you completed this
course of humanities one extra thing
that you can add to your when you go out
into the workforce so the other college
is ripe for entrepreneurial innovation
John Ocean Springs Mississippi you're on
the line with author Steve Forbes I have
at Forbes hereo I really good I'm
interesting you have thought on the
Obama health care repeal and I'm
wondering why you didn't look at the
butch chair might be prescription drug
for red as we be repealed that program
cost about seventy billion dollars a
year and they had a half drug costs in
the world I believe what I have a v-8 I
have the VA program and would negotiate
good places we get half of what Medicare
what people eat program has because the
Bush plan is role negotiations in it so
I think you'd like to where you feel the
path need prescription drug plan rates
let's get a response thank you John
in term terms of the what they cause I
think Part B of Medicare which is the
the drug plan
think that's it maybe it's part C but
anyway the challenge there is again the
whole medical whole medical system
healthcare system does not have real
free markets and one of the things that
needs badly need reform is the whole
area of approval of new drugs the Food
and Drug Administration largely still
has the mentality of the 1950's
for example they love clinical trials
which back then made sense but for a lot
of these new drugs today for cancer
washing you have to take a placebo when
there might be something already there
that can help you out with a disease
that can kill you and so they've got a
radically reform and I think if you get
the effective reform there and so you
don't have to spend two billion dollars
to bring a new drug to market which is
what you have now when you when you go
overseas for example those countries and
they buy drugs from our companies here
in effect get it at low cost because
they don't pay for the research and
development that two billion dollars
that went into the create the drug so if
we get reform there you get you'll get
more drug makers right now a company
that starts out with a promising drug
often has to sell out or partner with an
existing drug company to get through the
maze at the FDA which ends up costing us
so again I think that would be ripe for
reform and what the George W Bush did on
that part even though the cost came in
below estimation was one thing where
government didn't underestimate the cost
you're right that it's a whole part of
the brightened part of the whole problem
and caused a lot of anger among
Republicans which eventually led to
their defeat in the 2006 so yeah more
more more free markets more consumer
patient choice and will get again it
sounds utopia in health care but it will
work we've seen pieces of it where you
will get more for less Jim Anchorage
Alaska hi Jim Oh Steve thanks for taking
my call I got a small question on
concerning healthcare currently when a
person is discharged from hospital he or
she can receive bills one two three six
months a year later and these bills come
from the labs the doctors the hospital
they're all so hard to read it looks to
me as though with computers and if all
groups that bill knew this that when
that patient left the hospital they have
one bill they would have their bills
there on time and the patient would more
easily know if the charges were
applicable to that particular operation
or whatever I was just wondering what do
you see is an impediment to this type of
billing when you get a car fixed you get
one bill you don't get a bill and that's
the bolts the person that's working
someplace else you don't get different
different costs coming in and learning
what your thoughts are on implementing
such of a procedure well you hit on a
system where the patient is really not
the customer but the third parties
government and large insurers the
insurance companies the government and
employers and when if you ask if you go
to a hospital or clinic today and you
ask what a treatment is going to cost
and because we've grown up with the
system we don't realize how strange this
is you get a very strange look it means
either you're uninsured or you're crazy
why would you want to know the price
what's it to you they tell you oh
insurance will take care of it and then
we'll send you if there's a you owe
anything so they want to keep you
passive and they want to keep you
ignorant and that's the way the system
is geared whereas if you start making
these reforms where the patient has that
consumer power they know they they have
to look and and you're going to be
saying yes or no on whether they get
paid there will be a lot different
attitude even with computers today you
cannot read unless you're a genius the
bills that you get and you try to file
for a claim and by golly affront
Kafka wrote about trying to cope with
bureaucracies you feel absolutely lost
and bewildered and no hotel or if you
point out with a car repair would dare
give you a bill that you normally get
from a hospital and because it's third
party paid and not you the patient you
you you end up getting you know they say
well the insurance company takes three
months to decide how much of a $500
thing is they're going to cover and how
much they you're going to cover they
have over 20,000 different diagnosis
diagnosis whatever they call them so you
have to talk of your doctor if one if
it's one kind of particular diagnosis an
insurance won't cover it or maybe only
cover 50% but if it's almost like it you
they'll cover 85% so you trigger the
diagnose it's an insane system that's
why we've got to get it simplified back
to you the consumer and you won't get
these crazy situations you'll know in
advance when you're in charge the
hospitals in advance the clinics in
advance will tell you this is what it's
going to cost you see little signs of in
Pennsylvania there's a hospital chain
called Geisinger and several years ago
they instituted legally they can't call
them warranties but in effect if they
don't do something right the the
procedures on them so if they've botched
the knee operation the next ones on them
and you think in a normal market
everyone else would quickly have to do
that like with the automobiles if one
company says we'll give you a ten year
warranty with all this that and the
other thing the others quickly follow
suit hasn't happened in health care
because it's third party pay and not you
the patient and so you get you get
hospital rooms will look like an old
boarding house everyone jammed in and
it's it we've grown up with it so we
don't realize how unnecessary and crazy
it is even though a lot of that
equipment is fantastic a lot of smart
people the system itself just is not
working gary is calling in from Lopez
Island Washington hi Gary you're on with
author Steve Forbes hey Steve scare your
friends from Freedom Fest reading some
stage plays
together oh boy neither of us are in
Hollywood yes I wanted to ask you about
the gold standard it seems like it's
impractical but on the state level some
state legislatures are advocating gold
some state school systems are come are
stockpiling gold and overseas central
banks like Russia China Kazakhstan so
many others are favoring gold over paper
is it possible that that kind of a
creeping gradual gold standard will
start internationally and here in the
United States well I think getting a
gold standard one is and this is one
reason why we wrote the book is so the
people get an understanding of what the
thing actually is not this myth in
Crested the thing that we're told by
economists it's very simple like having
a ruler with 12 inches doesn't restrict
the size of a building you wish to
construct it just means you have a basis
of measurement to make it possible to do
construction efficiently and safely same
thing with the economy having a stable
currency and so they're the the what you
might call the idea framework is
beginning to be laid the Chinese have
been studying this for several years I
wouldn't be surprised if in the next
decade
they don't mess up their economic
reforms are trying to do now China goes
to a gold standard before we do they are
they're beginning to realize the
necessity of a stable currency and so I
think yes it's beginning to happen and
the more we get people studying it what
it really is and what it isn't I think
you're right it will happen and the
state level the states can contribute to
it by doing what the utah and others
have done and one of the things we could
do in the meantime in this country is
remove the barriers against alternative
currencies so if you want to establish
your own currency you willyou you're
free to do so and you don't have to
worry about the FBI throwing you in jail
it's not counterfeiting this is just
having an alternative currency and
especially with high-tech it becomes
more and more feasible so remove all
those
is tax barriers regulatory barriers and
something might emerge in the
marketplace we can't even conceive of
today well here's a text message from
the seven-one-seven area code I think
that's Pennsylvania somewhere mr. Forbes
what do you think about mr. Trump's idea
of bringing jobs back from China we
won't bring jobs back what we'll do if
we do things right here as we outline in
the book foreign companies will be
investing here on a level we can't even
imagine we got a little flavor of that
in the 80s when we started to move ahead
in the rest of the world auto
manufacturers came here because turns
out we could make cars as good as anyone
else if we didn't have crazy work rules
chemical companies are coming here now
because we have low energy costs so you
get the right environment and capital
will flow into this country and who
knows in terms of manufacturing what
will be done with 3d printing and other
technological advances in terms of
making robots robots have been with us
for forever we don't realize it a
washing machine's a form of a robot
instead of washing with hands we
machines do it same thing with dishes
and the like so but now with the laser
technology they can be precise in a way
and cheap in a way where you can make
clothes that are now done in the third
world we will be able to do it you won't
need many people but that laser
technology very very promising so
instead of thinking it was losing
creating I want to environment where
everyone wants to come here because we
have a good currency good legal system
good tax system and you want to be here
and people when they look at they're on
certain government's they're around the
world even now with all our troubles we
aren't trouble but we're better off than
most of the rest of the world which is
why they want their kids to go to school
here why they want to have real estate
here they realize this is a safer place
than just about anywhere else in the
world and that most recent book by Steve
Forbes and Elizabeth Eames reviving
America how repealing Obamacare
replacing the tax
code and reforming the Fed will restore
hope and prosperity want to play some
video you'll be able to see it right
there
and you'll know what this is about it's
from March of this year
good Steve Forbes like me and they put
me down at 4.5 billion net worth I'm not
complaining but it's much more than that
okay and I couldn't understand why is it
that Forbes they just raised me four
hundred million dollars this year now I
should be happy right and I am happy
what difference does it make
but I couldn't understand why are the
Forbes numbers so much lower than the
value of what I've built what was that
about mr. Forbes it up well Donald Trump
always thinks we underestimate his
wealth and we go through this every year
and the essence of it is putting aside
various properties the essence of it is
he thinks we should put several billion
value just on the value of his name and
in terms of how we value wealth we say
you monetize it and then we'll count it
as value we do this for everybody not
just Donald Trump Oprah and others yeah
you may have some value but you monetize
it you show that it's a worth something
we we count it that's the biggest that's
several B that's that's the big the big
difference and but he is ear oppressive
all I have to tell you a story I
shouldn't but I will what's in the
magazine we did a story on his wealth
the last fall for 400 richest list and
he disputed as he did there he thinks
it's much more and so reddit er went up
to his office was the same day the Pope
was in New York and so Crump Tower has a
balcony so went out on the balcony and a
lot of Latinos down there and so there
are some cheers for Donald Trump but
there are some boos as well and Trump
turns right at her and says you see 90%
approval and then he says this shows
also you've underestimated the value of
Trump Tower the Pope chose this building
to begin his New York parade and so he
is you know there's like Steve Jobs
Trump tries to make the world as he
thinks it should be and it can be a
shortcoming but are also convinced the
source of his strength he doesn't see
what's there he sees what he wants it to
be and that's what has made him own real
estate why he has these bill
the name on him he made it happen and by
the way whatever you think of them
one reason that he succeeded against all
expectations and people's minds when
they knew him because he's been on TV
for ten years seems a figure of
authority so they already felt they knew
him unlike every other candidate you
start out with even higher name
recognition than Jeb Bush far higher
they felt they knew Donald Trump and but
what would also help though is precisely
because he's in real estate a building
just doesn't happen so people can see
big building he made it happen
you don't give a speech in a building
rises up he made it happen and that's
what gave him the initial credibility
this was something more than software
software's
you don't feel it the way you can see a
big building or a big bridge or a golf
course or whatever that's what gave him
his original authority and again was we
were discussing earliest challenge now
now that he's got the nomination locked
up is taken to the next step and to
recognize everything he says now we'll
be examined
he thought he's examined earlier he
ain't seen nothing yet to what they're
going to try to do to him and so he's
got to put that team together and take
it to the next step where did the Forbes
400 come from came from my father back
in the early 80s so it would be
fascinating to see who had it who was
losing it who was making it what areas
it was coming from and so he said to our
editors we're going to do the 400 he
picked 400 because back in the late
1800s a man had the 400 of New York most
powerful people so it sounded like a
good number my father went with it and
our editors fought him tooth and nail
they said this is not like a publicly
traded company where you can add up with
what shares are worth and what the
company's capital isn't all that kind of
thing you know how can we do this and it
can't be done so I'm funny my father
said you're not going to do it I'm going
to take money and I'm going to hand do
it myself and so finally they
got got together and put the team
together and started to do it as we made
clear these are estimates some case you
get cooperation some cases you don't
know you've talked to bankers you talk
to competitors to get a get a good idea
of the range and my father's hunch was
right the the volatility each year you
get five ten fifteen percent change as
people move up go down we have lists who
who's on who is who came on was on few
years ago then fell off and came on
again energy sector obviously a lot of
those people have but taken a huge hit
and so it's the churn is quite amazing
and you see the same thing around the
world and we think of wealth as you know
piles of gold no it can be here today
and gone tomorrow as we found out and
look at look at the price of oil do
other people like Donald Trump dispute
or want to be on the list
Donald uh not only wants to be on the
list he thinks we never get it right
that we're always too too low even
though we've gone up several years ago
he's two billion he thought it was four
now we haven't for four and a half he
thinks it should be eight nine for ten
or pick pick pick a number so where were
always fifty percent behind and the way
he calculates it but most a lot of
others want to be off of it I think the
classic
case was a terms of complaint was a
fellow called up several years ago
furious and it wasn't so much our
estimate that he took issue with was
that he was on the list because he's in
the midst of the divorce and he didn't
want his wife to know what he had we
found it who is Sabina Beekman my wife
been married now almost forty five years
we met forty six and a half years ago
and at a party and sitting next to each
other
amazing out what chance plays on these
things and I being a smart aleck offered
her a cigar this is a posh club and
without missing a beat she took
get lit it up you want to be soothed if
you want to play that game again to miss
a moment and you have five daughters one
how many are involved in Forbes media
right now one Moira who heads up women's
side and conferences various conferences
just had a very successful one on
Women's Conference and the others too
were scattered around the country ones
in Dallas ones in the Seattle and so uh
but they they all got through the teen
years thanks to their mother and one one
thing I would recommend for parents with
especially with the teenage daughters
one is the mother just brace for it you
get it more than the father does and
remember in a very different context
what Lincoln said this too shall pass
Scott Halle Ryan tweets into you
Father's Day is coming up would he miss
most about your dad just the everyday
interaction he was one of these
originals who you never knew what was
going to come out of his mind he was
always thinking always seeing things and
so it was constant you know people they
say are addicted to their handhelds we
were always wondering what is he going
to come up with next that we wouldn't
have even conceived him like that the
issue of the four hundred and he was
intrepid talk about motorcycles you know
I wouldn't go ride one I love looking at
them they're beautiful things but as he
got older he rode them more instead of
less in his 50s late fifties he started
to commute to New York on a motorcycle
and even worse he started to ride in the
city you know New York City streets
pothole he started to ride in New York
and she had generational role-reversal
the kids telling the father dad these
are dangerous you can hurt yourself you
know he got to be careful and he did
have a least three serious accidents on
motorcycles one Neal he killed him
and didn't stop them any gifted one to a
list of Taylor he gifted one a purple
she's coming out with a purple passion I
think it was perfume and yes but he that
kind of gesture yes he loved doing and
he still have the plane or the ship we
don't the plane was a 727 and talked
about fuel consumption know what does
not work and the boat know that six
years ago became plane it was very good
for advertising getting getting business
because no one else had one but it had
lost its ability to attract business and
so Scottish blood came in cost-effective
no beautiful beautiful but doula is not
cost-effective and again that gets to
the tools change change with the times
next call for steve forbes dave Shaker
Heights Ohio hi Dave
hi good afternoon c-span and the
wonderful c-span audience and good
afternoon to you mr. Forbes I thank you
reader of your magazine the last 50
years on and off and it's given me some
wonderful wonderful ideas thank you okay
going on to Social Security I'm really a
little bit upset because if I talk to
ninety-nine out of a hundred people
everybody thinks it's not going to be
there it's going bankrupt and they are
so misinformed by I hate to say it a lot
of our media now the question is this
and here I'll draw the picture you
remember in the early 80s when Greenspan
Tip O'Neill and Ronald Reagan in a day
or two
Social Security had a fifty billion
dollar surplus in other words it was
close but not bankrupt but it was closed
today that surplus is close to three
trillion dollars now you started off in
the program your dad or grandfather said
money should bring happiness not pile up
don't you think it would be a wonderful
for our economy that the people who
helped get that surplus mainly the baby
boomers now get additional benefits but
for someone comes in and takes it and
literally steals your thoughts please
very interesting question and the sad
news is the money has already been
stolen it's already been spent that
three trillion surplus is when we're the
so-called trust fund is a trust fund in
name only the only thing that trust fund
has are io u--'s non-marketable from the
US Treasury Department when Social
Security money comes in when our payroll
taxes go in there immediately spent and
they give an IOU to the Social Security
Administration that's why you remember
five years ago we nearly had a default
on US government bonds because we
weren't going to raise the debt ceiling
and there are fears that people wouldn't
get their social security checks well if
you had a three trillion dollar surplus
and marketable government securities
that would pay for benefits for four or
five years six years but the money
wasn't there it already been spent now
if a private company did that took money
from their workers spend it and then
gave a non-marketable IOU those
executives would go to jail but in
Washington that's considered high
finance so well that three trillion two
and a half three trillion does not exist
and one of the things I hope the next
president will do then is take some of
these non-marketable IOUs and substitute
salable government bonds take them out
of the Federal Reserve there it's
complicated but I think it can be done
so that if you do get a crisis again you
don't have to worry about people not
getting their social security checks now
that three trillion also is supposed to
be a reserve like a pension fund or a
401k to pay future benefits it's not
just for those or on the system today
but not only pay what they get today but
make sure the reserves are there when
revenues start to fall come in less and
out goes go up as our baby boomer
generation retires so those are supposed
to be reserves like pension funds and
401ks and maleic and so in terms of
Social Security the key thing is we do
have enough wealth in the economy to pay
for the current promised benefits for
those are on the system and those are
going to go on the system for the next
ten or fifteen or twenty years the
problem comes with younger people people
in the teens 20s 30s there the system is
not going to be there for them because
it's pay-as-you-go there are no real
reserves there so that's why I think for
younger people they should put in a
system where part of their payroll tax
goes to their own personal accounts
plenty of our rules and regulations
about diversity diversifying they can't
spend it but it's their property right
now those benefits you pay in you know
each year you get a notice from Social
Security saying what you're going to get
under certain assumptions you think oh
this this is money that's there it isn't
the courts have ruled that the
government you don't own that money at
all even though you contributed it and
they make it sound like it's yours and
so you I want a system especially for
younger people where they actually own
that money own those assets so
politicians can't play games with it
like they do now where they say there's
a two and a half a three trillion dollar
surplus and it doesn't exist we
shouldn't do that to future generations
but in terms of the system today if we
get normal growth rates in this country
normal productivity the system for us
and for the next coming generation is
there to pay the promised benefits if we
continue to make idiotic mistakes which
would be doing recent years and there's
nothing going to be there for anybody
but so that's why I think we need to get
these reforms big three reforms in so we
have that resources there to meet the
promises to our generation in the next
generation but also bring in a new
system where we turn again like health
care liability into
acet because when kids get their first
part-time job start accumulating this
money that money is invested whether you
deposit with a bank or index fund or
whatever you do with it
it gets invested and that grows the
economy email to you mr. Forbes from Jay
s wimba at Buckeye Express comm flat tax
is meant to make the rich get richer
just like when Regan reduced the top
rate from seventy to forty percent a
gift to the millionaire's a three
hundred thousand dollar reduction in tax
on each successive one million in income
you are looking at things through the
eyes of the wealthy I'm looking at the
eyes through someone like most Americans
you want to see this economy grow again
so people who start with the least have
a chance to get more as Lincoln put it
and prove their lot in life and right
now and you have a stagnant economy who
gets hurt the most
incomes are not rising for low income
people they're not rising for middle
income earners we don't have the
mobility upward mobility we've had in
the past which is why we have the
political frustration today and so a
flat tax and that's why it's worked
around the world enables an economy to
focus our resources and our brain power
on productive things instead of this
idiotic tax code and so in terms of
growing incomes by the way John Kennedy
we always talk about Ronald Reagan John
Kennedy reduced income tax rates across
the board about twenty three twenty five
percent including the top and so you
could accuse him of favoring the rich
but what the Kennedys tax cuts when
they're finally enacted and Johnson led
to the booming 1960s Reagan's led to the
booming 1980s we created millions and
millions of new jobs including more and
more high paid jobs instead of these
part-time jobs yeah your town is
employed but you're not getting near
what you think you're worth and you're
right
so we want to get to the dynamism of a
growing economy and a flat tax is one
great way to do it and as for for tax
lawyers
and IRS agents even though I'm a
conservative I would support job
retraining or perhaps a urgently going
work for uber you know do something
useful
Becky Kurtz this is a tweet from Becky
Kurtz in Palm Desert California who is
the smartest person you know in and out
in or out of government and what's the
best run u.s. city and state in your
view the best run city and state
now let's interms of smart people one of
the things in is there a lot of smart
people and the key is it's not enough to
have the smarts you also have to have
judgment and a willingness to learn a
lot of people who have IQs that would
boil water but who can't seem to
translated into doing something big and
so yes a lot of brainpower but they come
to some you know conclusions that I just
disagree with so that's that's the
nature of life it's not enough to have
brain power you gotta have a lot of
other characteristics and by the way
people can also focus on a particular
area and do very well even if somebody
would say well they're not boiling the
water with their IQ that's not the key
thing I think in the early days and I
Google is getting back to it in terms of
computer programming that takes brain
power but they don't care if you if you
know how to do if you're really good at
it you or the kid and you start to
really get into this and okay if you
finish high school they don't care if
you finish college you can do the job
they want you and some of these jobs new
ten thousand a month ten thousand a
month one hundred thousand dollars
signing bonus hundred thousand dollars
in stock options so it's not the degree
it's what how you apply what you have
that I think we'll see more and more of
in this economy and so in terms of the
dynamism of the economy that's how
that's that's how we get ahead
again you get entrepreneurs people doing
things that come from the most unlikely
areas whether it's a middle-aged
milkshake machine salesman who vented
the modern restaurant industry or Henry
Ford couldn't run a corner grocery store
helping create one of the greatest
enterprises in the world it's an amazing
stories that can unfold all right to
take Becky's city state question you
have any thing that comes to mind or
well an option that you admire greatly
today well I mentioned he was former
governor of Indiana mitch daniels who
demonstrated in indiana over relentless
work not just one big thing but
relentless day-to-day work you can do
what government should do do it more
efficiently reduce taxes and turn a
state that should have been in a basket
case into one of the best credit ratings
in the country on the opposite side you
take the word grease and translate it in
English get Illinois where worst rated
credit estate in the country Chicago's
about to go broke the state I've got a
great governor but the legislature just
feels it's still lala land where you
don't have to worry about revenues so
it's a disaster and so i think mitch
Daniels an example of what can be done
with good leadership in Illinois what
happens when over time you have a series
of bad decisions made by golly they they
they they come to come to bite and
they'll give a good word to even though
people don't seem to like them anymore -
uh Scott Walker in Wisconsin those
reforms are starting to really tick in
and he took a lot of grief for I don't
know why that campaign was so
disastrously run but in Illinois he I
mean in Wisconsin he did real things
Wisconsin's always been a laboratory
whether the LaFollette ii-era
progressive era
whether it's welfare reform starting
tommy Thompson the 80s became the basis
for Clinton's welfare reform in the mid
90s and
what Walker has done so that's what
federalism is supposed to be about so
you see what works and then we can maybe
do it nationally
just a few minutes left with our custody
forbs here on book TV babi Townsville
South Carolina yes first time caller
from kind of nervous I'm 50 but when I
was 45 my family has a history of heart
disease and I played golf the league
before through black batting practice to
16 19 year olds and played softball but
that Friday I had a heart attack when I
was 45 hey I apologize Bobby but I'm
we're running out of time if you could
um get to your question for mr. Forbes I
will have a little tip now all right and
Thank You Cerie oh thanks for calling in
Ron is in Orford New Hampshire hi Ron I
thank you for taking my call Steve I
want to ask you about the tax that's
implemented with the Uniting amendment
it's a it's a flat tax but it has no
exemptions and no deductions at all so
the a revenue neutral flat tax with
those conditions is about a half a
percent an attack is everything and any
advantages are the you know it gets rid
of distortions of our current system
that under taxes the intermediate sales
and it would have side effects like
discouraging high frequency stock
trading and making long term investments
more more tax efficient and the poor
would only pay a half a percent on their
income so I was wondering which people
you thought about that tax anything that
slow is the music to my ears so if you
want to send me more detail on that and
we do have to get and get rid of the
sixteenth Amendment of the concert
do something where the tendency is
whenever you bring in a new tax it stays
and the other taxes stay and very very
hard to get them down once they're
implanted so yeah let me know what the
idea is when you say tax everything that
encompasses a lot of things I want to be
sure I know what what what exactly we're
getting into Thank You Neville Cleveland
Ohio hi Neville I'd like to ask whether
your client has got any opinion about
philanthropy you know Warren Buffett and
Bill Gates say a lot about philanthropy
I've been listening so far I've not
heard mr. Forbes say anything about
philanthropy does he have an opinion
about the way wealthy people distribute
or pass on their funds to other people
or the groups other nations what do you
think Neville I mean what do you think
that the view should be what is your
point my opinion is that Warren Buffett
and Bill Gates are setting a fine
example thank you sir Steve Forbes up
one of the amazing things about the
United States is that we are the most
philanthropic nation in the world cash
gifts or over three hundred billion
dollars a year that doesn't count the
millions tens of millions hundreds of
millions of hours that people contribute
in terms of volunteer time and that's
been true almost from our very existence
and we're also the most commercial
nation ever invented and people think
they're opposite poles they're not
commerce is about meeting the needs and
wants of other people effective
philanthropy the same thing and many
many examples you mentioned gates and
the Buffett of people have done very
well in the private sector are also very
effective in philanthropy what Gates is
doing in terms of fighting malaria and
other diseases very very inspiring what
he's trying to do in education
and I think Warren Buffett made a very
good point we do a philanthropy
conference each year and one of the
puppet one of the points that Buffett
likes to make is that in terms of you're
an entrepreneur and want to get involved
in philanthropy don't go for the things
that have already been done what he
calls the relatively easy things go for
something where you have a high risk of
failure go out of the bounds frontiers
try to try to make things happen you may
may not work for awhile just like a new
businesses most don't succeed but go on
the frontier and go out of your comfort
zone and try to make things happen that
others haven't done yet now to be
effective philanthropist
so in terms of the reforms one of the
things we point out in the book on the
tax side is when the American people
have more they give more they don't need
to be bribed by the tax code even before
we had an income tax we are a very
philanthropic nation and in the 1980s
just closed one story in the 1980s a lot
of philanthropies thought that when
Reagan cut the top rate from 70%
eventually went down to 28% that that
would hurt charitable giving because the
Uncle Sam in effect wouldn't be
subsidizing 70% of the dollar given but
only 28 cents of each dollar given but
what happened was the opposite people
not only gave more but the rate of
growth went up as well
so when people have more they give more
and in this country research shows that
roughly in the American people in cash
gifts give about 2% equivalent of 2% GDP
a year so that's about roughly three
hundred and fifty billion dollars and in
good times it may go up a little bit to
2.2 and rough times and may go down a
little bit 1.8 but it's fairly constant
so the bigger the economy the more
people give more people have the more
they give Steve Forbes we tried to do
this program back in April what happened
we had a train accident I was coming
down on the Acela Amtrak and outside of
Philadelphia and suddenly the train came
to an abrupt halt
not the kind of thing normally Sloane
down around a curve or anything
fortunately I was in we're in the last
car back of the Train and so we are
jolted in our coffee flew and things
flew but thankfully we didn't in the
front of the Train you had some real
injuries and sadly two workers how it
came that you had people working on a
track of the train coming on in this day
and age especially those two two workers
were killed and so we're in the back car
we stopped nothing was said now I wish
they would have an intercom system for
an emergency where they can say stay
calm we didn't go out of the Train
because there's a crack on one side
crack on the other we weren't going to
risk that so is about a half hour later
there are rumors people coming back and
forth and before the first responders
came there's been an accident don't move
I will tell you when to get off and in
about 15-20 minutes later we went off
walk carefully down the steps went
across the tracks went across the field
and thankfully in this town there was a
church that had an adjacent gymnasium
and we could go in there and wait to see
what would was going to happen and the
the Amtrak police had the manifest so
they knew who was on so the check names
to make sure no one was missing and and
yet you don't know in these situations
and so we waited and this buses came you
arrange kindly for a car for for me to
get me back back home since I wasn't
going to get here on time and but they
they still haven't come up with a
definitive report on what happened on
that but and thankfully I was not in the
front cars because then the Irian
injuries would have been very serious
instead of just losing your coffee and
getting a jolt and you came down on the
train today crane today uneventful
uneventful good good
Steve Forbes his most recent book is
reviving America how repealing Obamacare
replacing the tax
odhh and reforming the Fed will restore
hope and prosperity this has been book
TV on c-span 2 in depth
see spam created by America